IN EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT%
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES. WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING SAID TO
HEAR TO DISTRICT SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
THE NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES. TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE
HADN'T ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS. TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. CRAWL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT AGAIN NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR I'LL SAY THE-
TELEPHONE NUMBER AGAIN. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SIX NINE EIGHT. FOUR
FIVE NINE TWO THE ACCESS CODE
AGAIN IS. SIX NINE EIGHT FOUR
FIVE NINE TWO. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS YOU
CAN REFER TO THE SENATE FOR THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL.
ONE FOUR ZERO NINE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT FOR
THE WAIT PATIENTLY FOR THE
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
THEY'LL ASSIGN YOU MY NUMBER-
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. AND
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR NUMBER
YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE QUEUE. FOR THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT
TIME HE'LL BE ON MUTED AND THEN
YOU'LL BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY. SO BEFORE YOU START
TO SPEAK PLEASE MUTE THE DEVICE
YOU'RE LISTENING TO THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING ON. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE WANT TO THANK YOU AND
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE AND
YOUR PARTICIPATION. ON A
PERSONAL NOTE I THINK WE'VE GOT
MORE PUBLIC COMMENTS SINCE
WE'VE GONE REMOTE- THAN WHEN WE
WERE IN PERSON AND I THINK- TO
POT ONE POSITIVE BY PRODUCT OF
THE TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM. IT'S
A LOT MORE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARINGS AS
IS CUSTOMARY. IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL- WHO DISRUPTS. MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION MUTED. IT'S ALSO A
GOOD TIME TO REMIND EVERYBODY
THAT PROVIDING TESTIMONY THAT
THIS IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE. SO
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO
THE PHYSICAL ASPECTS OF THE
BILLS BEFORE US TODAY- WE ARE
NOT GOING TO BE RE LITIGATING
THE POLICY- JUST DEALING WITH
THE FISCAL SO PLEASE CONFINE
YOUR TESTIMONY. TO THOSE WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE HEARING PROCESS. AND
CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS AND IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR TRIP FOR
PARTICIPANTS FOR JUSTIN TO THE
NEW ONLINE TOOLS. WE'LL TRY TO
BE PATIENT AND WE HOPE YOU TRY
TO BE PATIENT AS WELL. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL OF ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES. WE HAVE SEVENTY ONE
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA WE HAVE
ONE BILL ELIGIBLE FOR A DO PASS
MOTION WE HAVE ONE AUTHOR WHO
DID NOT WAIVE PRESENTATION-
WHICH SO WE'LL HEAR FROM THAT
AUTHOR- ALTHOUGH ALL THE OTHER
AUTHORS- CHOSE TO. DO THAT
COURTESY. THE REMAINING BILLS
ARE SUSPECT KATNISS SPENT CAN
SUSP. REMAINING BILLS ARE SUS
CANDIDATES. WHILE THEY MAY BE
SAYS TO BUT SUSPENSE CANDIDATES.
FOR MOST OF THE AUTHORS-
SEVERITY SAID THAT PART- WE
WILL. THOUGH THE AUTHORS WHO OF
WAY PRESENTATION WILL ALSO
PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
PUBLIC. TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY ON
ALL MATTERS SO EVEN IF. YOUR
FAVORITE AUTHOR HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION- WE WILL STILL BE
OPENING UP EACH ITEM FOR
PUBLIC. TESTIMONY BEFORE WE
HEAR PRESENTATIONS OF ALL THE
BILLS WERE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO MR
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. UNDER PORTANTINO I'M
HERE YOUR BATES. BRADFORD
EASIER BRADFORD HERE HILL YOUR
BILL HERE JONES. JONES HERE
LEYVA. YEAH LEYVA HEREBY
CASKEY- CASKEY HERE WE HAVE A
CORE. WE HAVE A QUORUM- I WILL
NOTE FOR THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO GET
EVERYTHING DONE BY SESSION BUT
IF WE DON'T TO WILL HAVE TO BE
BACK THIS AFTERNOON TO FINISH.
THE BUSINESS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THAT WILL BE MOVING THROUGH THE
AGENDA IN FILE ORDER- BUT ALL
BILLS AUTHORED BY AN INDIVIDUAL
MEMBER WILL BE TAKEN UP. AT THE
SAME TIME WE DO THAT AUTHOR.
WE'VE INCLUDED A COPY OF OUR
BILL BY BILL AGENDA ON THE
FRONT PAGE OF THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE WHICH IS W. W. W. DOT
S. A. P. R. DOT SENATE DOT CA
DOT G. OVIE. IF ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WANT TO FOLLOW ALONG
TO THE CONSTRAINTS. REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS AND
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS
INCLUDING PRO PROTOCOLS.
COMMITTEE CHAIRS ARE GOING TO
INSTITUTE A TIME TESTIMONY SO
I'M GONNA HAVE TWO MINUTES. FOR
EACH SIDE OF THE PRIMARY
TESTIMONY AND THEN EVERYONE
ELSE WILL BE. A ME TOO WHICH
WILL MEAN. JUST STATE YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION- AND I MEAN TO BE
STRICT ON THAT AND SO. OUR
FIRST ITEM IS FROM. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ IT'S ON- THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE SHE'S WAY
PRESENTATION SO WE'LL MOVE
RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IT'S
AB SIXTY SIX. ON POLICE USE OF
FORCE. IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE IN SUPPORT.
OF AB SIXTY SIX. SEEING NO ONE
HERE I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS
NOBODY IN ROOM. TWENTY FORTY
AND SO I'M SORRY ONE ONE ROSE
FROM ONE TWELVE TODAY ROOM ONE
TWELVE THERE'S NOBODY DOWN
THERE THEY'LL LET US KNOW IF
ANYBODY SHOWS UP SO WE'RE GONNA
MOVE PAST THAT AND GO RIGHT TO
OUR ONLINE SYSTEM. ANYBODY IS
ONLINE IN SUPPORT OF AB. SIXTY
SIX. AND AGAIN ANYONE WHO
WISHES HE COULD SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTY THANKS PLEASE PRESS ONE
THE NEW ZERO PRESS ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE A COMMENT TO THE
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT POINT EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. HELLO WE CAN HEAR YOU ARE
YOU HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB. SIXTY SIX. NO I AM I AM
OPPOSING. AB FIVE IN THE
AMENDMENTS OKAY SO THAT'S AND
LATER ITEM. ON THAT THAT'S A
LATER ITEM MA'AM. OKAY
MODERATOR SONORA JOHN AB SIXTY
SIX. AND AGAIN IT IN FAVOR OF
AB SIXTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. JUST A MOMENT. WILL
NOW HEAR FROM ONE SIXTY SEVEN.
JERRY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
QUALITY CALIFORNIA IS THE PORT.
SURE THERE'S NO ONE ELSE THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT WE WILL COME BACK
TO THIS COMMITTEE ROOM IS THERE
THERE'S NO ONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION. OF AB SIXTY SIX-
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SIXTY SIX A MODERATOR PLEASE GO
TO THE PHONE LINES. PROPOSITION
AB. SIXTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME IF WE
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
ONE SURE THERE'S NO WINNING
QUEUE THE COMMENT ALL RIGHT
WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. RIGHT
MORNING MISTER CHAIR GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
BILL AT BUT WE NOTE THAT
ALTHOUGH THE BILL DOESN'T
EXPLICITLY REQUIRE TRAINING-
AND ONLY PROHIBITS THE USE OF
KINETIC ENERGY PROJECTILES OR
CHEMICAL AGENTS. ARE GIVEN THE-
HUNDREDS OF LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. THAT THIS
BILL COULD REQUIRE TRAINING FOR
A WEEK THANK YOU TO THIS COST
COULD BE UNKNOWN BUT
POTENTIALLY VERY SIGNIFICANT.
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULDN'T- THAT
THE BILL COULD IMPOSE A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE A
SAUDI ASSOCIATED WITH
INCREASING THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS OF LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. THE
SIEGE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
I DO NOT HAVE FISCAL ESTIMATES
AT THE TIME OF OUR ANALYSIS-
BUT IT'S LIKELY THESE
DEPARTMENTS WOULD INCUR
SIGNIFICANT COSTS TO RETRAINING.
FINALLY THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE ESTIMATES UNKNOWN BUT
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT ONE
TIME COST OF BETWEEN FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION AND THIRTEEN POINT
FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND. AN
ONGOING COST OF TWO POINT TWO
MILLION GENERAL FUND RELATED TO
MONITORING INCOME COMPILING
DATA FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIXTY SIX WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE WILL MOVE ON TO AB
ONE NINETY SIX. WHAT THE RECORD
SHOWS BATES IS HERE GOOD
MORNING PAT. AB ONE NINETY SIX
BY MISS GONZALEZ ON WORKERS
COMPENSATION- IS THERE ANYONE
IN THIS IS ALSO A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WITH NO. TESTIMONY IS
ANYONE HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE FOR SUPPORT OF ONE NINETY
SIX. SEEING NONE THERE'S NO ONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE SO MODERATOR
WE WILL GO TO. THE PHONE LINE
FOR TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
ONE NINETY SIX. THANK YOU CARE
AND AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE ZERO IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN FAVOR OF
THE EIGHTY ONE NINETY SIX.
THERE IS NO ONE IN KILL. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK HERE
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE NINETY SIX
THERE'S NO ONE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE. THERE'S NO ONE IN ONE
TWELVE MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
GO ON BACK YOU UP THE PHONE
LINE ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION. OF
AB. ONE NINETY SIX.
PROPOSITIONAL AB ONE NINETY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE ZERO.
MISTER THERE'S NO WINNING QUEUE
FOR THAT. ALL RIGHT MEANS THAT-
WE DO HAVE ONE PERSON JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE OKAY. AND WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO LINE NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS EVAN PELLICANO HAD
INTERPRETED FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA LESS PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES IT IS AMENDED TO
INCLUDE TRANSLATORS AND
INTERPRETERS RIGHT. NOW WE'RE
NOT ON THAT BIT MA'AM WE'RE NOT
ON THAT BILLS SO WE'RE ON BILL
ONE NINETY SIX TO PLEASE PEOPLE
COULD FOLLOW THE AGENDA WOULD
HELP- IS THERE ANYONE ONLINE
WHO IS IN OPPOSITION OF ONE
NINETY SIX. THE TEACHER THERE'S
NO WINNING QUEUE. ALL RIGHT WE
ONE THAT WAS OPPOSITION RIGHT
MISTER. MODERATOR OKAY WE WILL
GO TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
AB. ONE NINETY SIX. AND WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
BILL BUT KNOW THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ESTIMATES THE OVERALL
FISCAL IMPACT. IS UNKNOWN BUT
AT A MINIMUM ESTIMATES COSTS
COULD BE BETWEEN SIX POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS INITIALLY AND
FIVE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
ON GOING FROM THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION. ALL THE FRONT TO
HANDLE INCREASED WORKERS
COMPENSATION REQUIRED.
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HUMAN RESOURCES REPORTS UNKNOWN
BUT SIGNIFICANT COST TO THE
STATE AS GOVERNMENT FACILITIES
ARE AMONG THE SIXTEEN CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE SIX SECTORS
DEEMED ESSENTIAL. AND LASTLY
ARE THERE ADDITIONAL STATE
DEPARTMENTS. DID AND ON COSTS
RELATED TO INCREASE WORKERS
COMPENSATION PREMIUM COSTS
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THERE'S ANY
MEMBER HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SOMEONE NINETY SIXTEEN
NO HANDS GO UP. WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB ONE NINETY SIX
WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO AB. TEN SIXTY
SIX. AB TEN SIXTY SIX AT THE
BATTLE OF HASTINGS MR WHITE
HOUSE. TEN SIXTY SIX. THE NEXT
ITEM FROM HIS GONZALEZ IS ON
UNEMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION IS
THERE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT OF TEN SIXTY SIX SEEING
NINE THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE MISTER MODERATOR WE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINE FOR
SUPPORT FOR A BI. TEN SIXTY
SIX. THANK THE TEACHER PLEASE
PRESS ONE ENTER AT THIS TIME IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF.
TEN SIXTY SIX. THERE IS NO
WINNING QUEUE. ALL RIGHT
ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM IN
OPPOSITION TO TEN SIXTY SIXTEEN
NOBODY THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE IN OPPOSITION TO TEN
SIXTY SIX IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE. OPPOSED TO A.
B. TEN SIXTY SIX. IN OPPOSITION
PRETEND CLICK CLICK TO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. AS CHAIR
THERE'S NO WINNING Q. R. I.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE STEP OF
FILING. TEN SIXTY SIX. YES
MISTER CHAIR WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION- BUT WOULD KNOW THAT.
THIS BILL'S PROVISIONS WOULD
HAVE AN UNKNOWN BUT LIKELY
SIGNIFICANT COST TO THE STATE'S
DISABILITY INSURANCE FUND AN
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FUND TO
RECOVER COLLECT EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM EMPLOYERS I
WOULD KNOW THAT THE U. I. FUND
IS CURRENTLY INSOLVENT DUE TO
RECORD HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT AS A
RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC. IN THE-STATE IS BORROWING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO CONTINUE
U. S. TEAMS. RIGHT THANK YOU
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TEN SIXTY SIX WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY SIX BY MS
GONZALEZ ON. SMALL DOLLAR LOANS
AGAIN SHE'S WAY PRESENTATION
THERE'S NO ONE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE IN SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE IN SUPPORT.
WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE
MODERATORS OR ANYBODY IN ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWENTY ONE NINETY SIX. PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO BE WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF. TWENTY ONE
NINETY SIX. THERE IS NO WINNING
QUEUE. ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME
BACK FOR OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO
AB TWENTY ONE NINETY SIX
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE OPPOSED AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY SIX. IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO AB.
TWENTY ONE NINETY SIX. PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO COUPON.
THERE'S NO ONE IN CHAIR THERE
WAS NO WINNING Q. ALL RIGHT IS
THERE ANY FINANCE. FILE ON
TWENTY ONE NINETY SIX. I DON'T
HAVE A FILE ON THE **** MEASURE
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU SEEING
NO HANDS OF MY COLLEAGUES GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
YES NOW THE MOMENT WE'VE ALL
BEEN WAITING FOR I AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTY SEVEN BY MS GONZALEZ
ON WORKER CLASSIFICATIONS AND
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS- SHE
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT AND THERE'S NO LINE AND
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WE ARE GOING TO THE
SUPPORT. SESSION ON AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTY SEVEN SO IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED. WAIT YOUR TURN THIS IS
THE SUPPORT. MOMENT MISTER
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF TWENTY TWO FIFTY
SEVEN ON THE PHONE LINE. MISTER
CHAIR WE DO HAVE PEOPLE QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME. AND WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE LINE SEVENTY
FIVE POINT SEVENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. JUST REGARD
PLEASE VISIT OUR OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT WAIT YOUR TURN THANK
YOU GOING TO GO LINE. TWENTY
ONE. ADRIAN BROWN CAN I IT
REPRESENT AND INDEPENDENT MUSIC
PROFESSIONALS UNITED I'M AN
INDEPENDENT MUSICIAN AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWO TWO
FIVE SEVEN AND THE MUSICIANS
EXTENSION THANK YOU. ONE
SEVENTY FOUR. HELLO MY NAME IS
JULIAN PURSER I'M A FREELANCE
TRANSLATOR IN CONFERENCE
INTERPRETER A NICE PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES ARE INTENDED TO
INCLUDE TRANSLATORS AND
INTERPRETERS OF WHICH ARE
PROFESSIONALS I WHOLEHEARTEDLY
OPPOSE OKAY WE ARE ON THE
SUPPORT FOR TWENTY TWO FIFTY
SEVEN AGAIN EVERYBODY ONLINE
WHO'S LISTENING THIS IS THE
SUPPORT PORTION IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED JUST BE PATIENT LIST
MODERATOR PLEASE INSTRUCT
PEOPLE. HOW TO DO THIS.
BENNIGAN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
AT THIS TIME WE ARE TAKING
COMMENT. PORT I'M GONNA GO TO
THE LINE OF LINE FOURTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
KAREN GERRITY I AM A MUSICIAN A
CONTRACTOR AND A MEMBER OF
INDEPENDENT MUSIC PROFESSIONALS
UNITED IN SUPPORT OF. TWENTY
TWO FIFTY SEVEN. I'M GONNA GO
TO LINE. ONE THIRTEEN. YES THIS
IS TOM SHE HE ON BEHALF OF THE
LANGUAGE ACCESS PROFESSIONALS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT IF
AMENDED AND WE APPRECIATE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND HER
STAFF THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
WHAT. ONE OH NINE. BY ONE OH
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M
SORRY THIS IS IN OPPOSITION
OKAY GET BACK IN THE QUEUE.
FLYING THIRTY SEVEN. MY NAME IS
WORTH IT DAVID GOOD AMERICA
TRANSLATING SERVICES UNLESS
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES IS
AMENDED TO INCLUDE TRANSLATORS
AND INTERPRETERS I OPPOSE THANK
YOU AGAIN THIS IS THE SUPPORT
PORTION SUPPORT NOT OPPOSITION
SUPPORT. AND FINALLY WE'LL GO
TO LINE. ONE SEVENTEEN. HI THIS
IS SANDY EISENBERG I AM IN
SUPPORT IS AMENDED FOR SIGN
LANGUAGE INTERPRETERS AND REAL
TIME CAPTIONS FOR THE DEAF AND
HARD OF HEARING COMMUNITY THANK
YOU OKAY THAT WAS THE LAST
SUPPORT. THE MINISTER CARE OKAY
WE'RE GONNA COME BACK TO THIS
ROOM FOR OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY OPPOSED HERE THERE'S
NOBODY OPPOSED. IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE OKAY MISTER MODERATOR
QUEUE UP ALL OF THE FOLKS WHO
ARE OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY SEVEN THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR OPPOSED. PLEASE
CONFINE YOURSELF TO YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION THANK YOU. AND AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AT THIS
TIME IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. PRESS ONE NINE
ZERO. ZERO NINE EIGHTY FOUR.
YES HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
PERFECT HI MY NAME IS HAVE A
THINKING I AM A PROFESSIONAL
FRAMING WHICH INTERPRETER AND
I'M GLAD I AB TWENTY SEVEN IS
AMENDED FOR INTERPRETERS
TRANSLATORS AND REAL TIME
CAPTIONING TO BE INCLUDED AS
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES I UPLOAD
ALL RIGHT IF THE FOLLOWING
SPEAKERS COULD JUST STATE YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION IN YOUR
POSITION THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE ONE OH
FOUR. BY ONE OF FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES THIS IS. BY ONE OF
FOUR YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
QUEUE UP AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO GUN WHEN TO GO TO LINE
THIRTY TWO. RIGHT ARE YOU CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES. YOUR MIND I AM
I AM I'M CHAU GIANG RENDON I'M
A FREELANCE TRANSLATOR AND THEN
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA TRAIN
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION BOARD
MEMBER. UNLESS THE SECTION ON
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES AS
AMENDED TO INCLUDES TRANSLATORS
AND INTERPRETERS I OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. LINE EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
BRIAN BRISCOE I AM A- CERTIFIED
INTERPRETER AND OWNER OF THE
BEST INTERPRETING AND- UNLESS
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES AS
AMENDED TO INCLUDE TRANSLATORS
AND INTERPRETERS. I OPPOSE. ONE
SEVENTY TWO. HELLO MY NAME IS
NEVER HOT BY DUTCH I'M TO PUT
PROFESSIONAL INTERPRETER UNLESS
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES IS
AMENDED TO INCLUDE TRANSLATORS
AND INTERPRETERS I'LL CALLS.
ONE SIXTY THREE. YES GOOD
MORNING. YES GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS KERRY VEGAS SPANISH
INTERPRETER UNLESS PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES AS AMENDED TO INCLUDE
TRANSLATORS AND INTERPRETERS I
OPPOSE. WHINY BRING. MY NAME IS
AND I ONLY HAS BEEN OPEN I'M A
THIRD. MY NAME IS AN LDS
SANCHEZ I'M A CERTIFIED MEDICAL
INTERPRETER IN SAN DIEGO I'M
NOT AB FIVE TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN
IT'S AMENDED. I WILL OPPOSE.
ONE THIRTY FOUR. FIVE ONE YOU
CALL YOUR GRANDMA COUNTY-
ACCOMPLISHMENT CLASSIFIED AS
MEDICAL EIGHT CHARACTERS UNLESS
PROFESSIONALS BOND AMENDED TO
INCLUDE TRUMP LATER. AND
INTERPRETER WHICH ONE OF OUR
VERY VERY HIGH ADVENTURE OUR
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
WE'RE JUST TAKING. NINE HELLO
MY NAME IS ON WILL TROUBLE I'M
A PROFESSIONAL TRANSLATOR ENTER.
AND UNLESS ALSO INDUSTRY
TRANSLATORS INTERPRETERS I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. ONE SIXTY
EIGHT. YEAH WARNING NAME IS
DESIREE OUR THE LANTERNS.
EVERYBODY ELSE I OPPOSED BILL
AND SENATE AND I TWO.
HEALTHCARE CENTER. ONE ONE OH
NINE. ONE ONE OH NINE YOUR LINE
OPEN. I DID MORE MY NAME IS BEN
CARR I'M AT PROFESSIONAL
TRAINED IN LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA HELLO. OF PERSONAL
THE MAN TO INCLUDE TRANSLATOR
AND INTERPRETERS. ONE FORTY
FIVE. ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WILL BE ON THE LINE
NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES HELLO MY NAME IS MELISSA
MEYER AND I'M THE CEO BARGATE
INTERNATIONAL ON THE BOARD
MEMBER ALSO FOR THE SENSATIONAL
LANGUAGE COMPANIES. AND I'M
LAST PROFESSIONAL SERVICES AND
AMEND IT TO INCLUDE TRANSLATORS
AND INTERPRETERS I COMPLETELY
OPPOSE. ONE FIFTY SIX. THE
MORNING MEETING WITH THE SMM
AMERICAN SIGN LANGUAGE
INTERPRETER AND LYFT
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES AMENDED
TO INCLUDE TRANSLATORS AND
INTERPRETERS I OPPOSE THANK YOU.
HELLO GO AHEAD. ASSEMBLY
ECONOMIC MERICAN BOMBING WHICH
INTERPRET EARNING LESS
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES WITH
AMENDED TO INCLUDE TRANSLATORS.
ONE ONE OLYMPIC. I YES I AM
HELEN REES- A COACH CERTIFIED
INTERPRETER AND UNLESS
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES AS
AMENDED TO INCLUDE TRANSLATORS
AND INTERPRETERS I OPPOSE. ONE
ONE FOURTEEN. YES HELLO MY NAME
IS ZACHARY SMITH A PROFESSIONAL
AMERICAN SIGN LANGUAGE
INTERPRETER AND SOLE
PROPRIETORS EACH
MISINTERPRETING LOCATED IN
FOLSOM CALIFORNIA UNLESS
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES AS
AMENDED TO INCLUDE TRANSLATORS
AND INTERPRETERS I OPPOSE. ONE
FIFTEEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
FRANCISCO HOLD SPENT ON A
CERTIFIED COURT INTERPRETER IN
SPANISH AND ENGLISH UNLESS THE
CATEGORY OF PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES THE MANDATE TO INCLUDE
INTERPRETERS AND TRANSLATORS TO
DIFFERENT PROFESSIONS I OPPOSE
AB TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN. THANK
YOU. ONE SEVENTY. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS YVONNE EVERY THAT'S
MEDICAL CERTIFIED INTERPRETER
IN ORANGE COUNTY UNLESS AMENDED
TO INCLUDE A PROFESSIONAL
TRANSLATORS AND INTERPRETERS
ARE YOU OPPOSED TO AB TWO TWO
FIVE SEVEN. I THINK BLACK AND
ONE TWENTY THREE. NAME IS
RICHARD AND FIND WITH
INTERPRETER READ DOT COM
BETWEEN INTERPRETERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AROUND THE WORLD.
UNLESS IT IS AMENDED WE OPPOSE.
ONE FIFTY FIVE. I AM NOW MARINO
PRESIDENT OF LIAISON
MULTILINGUAL SERVICES AND VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
LANGUAGE COMPANIES UNLESS
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES AS
AMENDED TO INCLUDE TRANSLATORS
AND INTERPRETERS I OPPOSE. ONE
THIRTY ONE. I AM A GROUP
ACTUALLY LUNCH HE GO TRANSLATOR
AND INTERPRETER IN SAN
FRANCISCO UNLESS PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES IS AMENDED TO INCLUDE
TRANSLATORS AND INTERPRETERS I
OPPOSE. BLIND ONE NO. ONE ONE
ONE TWENTY TWO. GOOD MORNING
I'M PATRICIA ALIGNMENT STATE
TERRIFIED SPANISH INTERPRETER
MAKINA I MUST PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES AS AMENDED TO INCLUDE
TRANSLATORS AND INTERPRETERS I
OPPOSE. ONE SIXTY THANK. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JENNIFER
SANTIAGO DREAMLAND CERTIFIED
HEALTHCARE INTERPRETER IN
GARDEN GROVE CALIFORNIA UNLESS
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES IS
AMENDED TO INCLUDE TRANSLATORS
AND INTERPRETERS I OPPOSE. ONE
FIFTY SEVEN. ONE FIFTY SEVEN
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS SEAMUS SAY
ADVISED PRESIDENT OF
INTERPRETERS UNLIMITED BASED IN
SAN DIEGO AND ALSO A BOARD
MEMBER OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
LANGUAGE COMPANIES AND
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES NOT
AMENDED INCLUDE INTERPRETERS
AND TRANSLATORS WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE. NINE FIFTY NINE. I'M
CARLA IT'S TO THIS PRESIDENT OF
THE INTERNATIONAL CONTACT THE
THIRTY EIGHT YEAR OLD COMPANY
IN BERKELEY CALIFORNIA I JUST
LOST THE RACE WITH THE CITY OF
BERKELEY YOU JUST HAVE TO FIND
TRANSLATION SERVICES AS
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES THEREFORE
UNLATCHED PROFESSIONAL SERVICES
IS A MEMBER OF THE TRANSLATORS
AND INTERPRETERS I OPPOSE ALL
RIGHT IF THE SUBSEQUENT LINE
WILL BE PUNISHED WHEN HE FIRED
IF THE SUBSEQUENT SPEAKERS
COULD CONFINE THEMSELVES. TO
THEIR TEAMMATES TO TURN THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR POSITION.
PLEASE SPEAK SIX SAYING THANK
YOU. BURKE. ONE ONE TWENTY
FIVE. TO THE ARTIST EVEN CANNOT
PRESIDENT CARTER'S LANGUAGE
SOLUTIONS- WHAT'S PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES AND MANAGED INCLUDE
TRANSLATORS INTERPRETERS I
OPPOSE. ONE FORTY THREE. YES MY
NAME IS MARIBEL VALENCIA
TALISMAN I'M A SPANISH MEDICAL
INTERPRETER ON LESS
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES IS
AMENDED TO INCLUDE TRANSLATORS
AND INTERPRETERS I OPPOSE THANK
YOU BY. ONE THIRTY FIVE. ONE
ONE THIRTY FIVE BILL ONE SPOKE
OUT HI MY NAME IS MARK TWAIN
AND I'VE BEEN AN INDEPENDENT
TRANSLATOR OF JAPANESE INTO
ENGLISH FOR MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS JUST STATE YOUR POSITION
LANGUAGE. I OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU. LINE ONE OF.
FOUR LORENA ORTIZ SCHNEIDER AND
THE CHAIR OF THE COALITION OF
PRACTICING TRANSLATORS AND
INTERPRETERS OF CALIFORNIA AND
UNLESS PROFESSIONAL SERVICES IS
AMENDED TO INCLUDE TRANSLATORS
AND INTERPRETERS I OPPOSE AB
TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN. BY. ONE
THIRTY ONE. THIS IS A BILL
PASADA CEO OF CALIFORNIA
INTERPRETS NETWORK WE OPPOSE-
AB TWO TWO SEVEN UNLESS
INTERPRETERS. NINE ONE OH
SEVEN. JEFF BY ONE OF SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS MARISSA
RAMOS I'M A CERTIFIED MEDICAL
INTERPRETER AND UNLESS
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES AS
AMENDED TO INCLUDE TRANSLATORS
AND INTERPRETERS I OPPOSED
THANK YOU. I NEEDED TO. MY NAME
IS CHAD WAS YES I AM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN
TRANSLATORS ASSOCIATION. I WAS
AB TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN AS
AMENDED ON PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES TO IMPROVE TRANSLATORS
AND INTERPRETERS WE SPEAK
STRONGLY IN OPPOSITION. ONE ONE
OH THREE. MY NAME IS DONNA
GONZALEZ AND I AM A CERTIFIED
MANAGE COURT AND MEDICAL
INTERPRETER AND LYFT
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES AMENDED
TO INCLUDE TRANSLATORS AND
INTERPRETERS I OPPOSE. ONE ONE
THIRTY THREE. MY NAME IS JULIAN
DRESSER ON THE PROFESSIONAL
FREELANCE TRANSLATOR REGISTERED
COURT INTERPRETER AND
CONFERENCE INTERPRETER IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND YES PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES ARE AMENDED TO INCLUDE
TRANSLATORS INTERPRETERS WHICH
ARE PROFESSIONALS ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU OWES. BY. NINETY
NINE. MY NAME IS TO THE MACHINE
BY SPREAD THEN ALL OF NOTHING
CALIFORNIA TRANSLUCENT SESSION
UNLESS PROFESSIONAL SERVICE IS
AMENDED TO INCLUDE INTERPRETER
AND TRANSLATOR I OPPOSE. ONE
SEVENTY ONE. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS JEANINE STROBEL I AM A
CERTIFIED SIGN LANGUAGE
INTERPRETER UNLESS PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES IS AMENDED TO INCLUDE
TRANSLATORS AND INTERPRETERS.
ONE THIRTY THREE. YOU CAN LET
THEM FINISH THEIR FINAL
STATEMENT MISTER MODERN THAT
THEY OPPOSE. YOU OUGHT. YES
MISTER CHAIR. ONE THIRTY. MY
NAME IS TONY BERRY I'M A
SPANISH CERTIFIED COURT
INTERPRETER. I LIVE
PROFESSIONAL SERVICE THE ARMY
IS AMENDED TO INCLUDE
TRANSLATORS AND INTERPRETERS I
OPPOSE. BY. SEVENTY FIVE. ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN. MY NAME IS ISABEL
WHAT DOES NOT AND I AM.
TRANSLATING INTO TOWN AND
BISHOP CALIFORNIA INYO ELECTRIC
PERSONAL SERVICES AS AMENDED TO
INCLUDE TRANSLATORS AND
INTERPRETERS I OPPOSE. ONE ONE
FORTY FOUR FOR. MY NAME IS EVA
BARISH I AM CERTIFIED SPANISH
AND HEBREW MANY PENDING
TEMPERATURE LESS PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES SOMEONE THIS INCLUDES
TRANSLATIONS AND INTERPRETERS I
OPPOSE. ONE NINETEEN. HI MY
NAME'S IN RETAIL AS I AM E.
TRANSLATOR AND INTERPRETER
UNLESS PROFESSIONAL SERVICES
AMENDED TO INCLUDE TRANSLATORS
AND INTERPRETERS I WILL PULL.
ONE ONE THIRTY NINE. PARDON ME
ONE BY ONE THIRTY NINE IS OPEN
NOW. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
MADELEINE SUCH AS APOLLO NO THE
PRESIDENT ELECT OF THE AMERICAN
TRANSLATORS ASSOCIATION AND A
CERTIFIED TRANSLATOR PLACENTIA
CALIFORNIA. OMAN'S AMENDED TO
INCLUDE PROFESSIONAL
TRANSLATORS AND INTERPRETERS
UNDER PROFESSIONAL SERVICES AYE
OPPOSED AB TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN.
ONE FORTY EIGHT. ONE ONE FORTY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
TERRY CENTER DONALD I'M NOT
CERTIFIED SIGN LANGUAGE
INTERPRETER AND UNLESS
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES IS
AMENDED TO INCLUDE INTERPRETERS
AND TRANSLATORS AYE OPPOSED AB.
TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN. BY ONE
FORTY FIVE. HI MY NAME IS MY
NAME IS APPLETREE CONGRESS
INTERPRETER. CHAU CHAVEZ SAID
IT AND THEN TO INCREASE TRACK
AND INTERPRETERS I A COLLEGE.
BY ONE THIRTY FOUR. MR GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ALBERT BELL
THIS STATE CERTIFIED SPANISH
INTERPRETER UNLESS PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES IS AMENDED TO INCLUDE
TRANSLATORS AND INTERPRETERS I
OPPOSE THANK YOU. THE. ONE ONE
FIFTY SIX. WARNING THIS
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SINGLE OUT OF
SEQUENCE CARL LONDON BEHALF OF
THE RECORDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA. ORDER
THE BILL ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA THERAPY ASSOCIATION
WE SUPPORTED IF IT'S AMENDED TO
INCLUDE SPECIFIED SITUATIONS.
D. THANK YOU. ONE ONE OH ONE.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS MARTINEZ I
AM A CERTIFIED COURT
INTERPRETER I OPPOSE Q. AB TWO
TWO FIVE SEVEN AND THAT
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES IN
AMENDED TO INCLUDE TRANSLATORS
AND INTERPRETERS THANK YOU. ONE
ONE FIFTY EIGHT. YES HELLO THIS
IS SHELLY BROWNING CERTIFIED
PLUMBING WHICH INTERPRETER AND
FOUNDER OF THE NATURE OF
INTERPRETING I OPPOSE THIS BILL
UNLESS AMENDED TO INCLUDE
TRANSLATORS INTERPRETERS
FINALLY WHICH INTERPRETERS AND
REAL TIME CAPTIONING THANK YOU.
ONE ONE SIXTY. HI THIS IS SAKET
CICERO CHAMA STATE CERTIFIED
MEDICAL INTERPRETER
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARING
INTERPRETER AND COURT
INTERPRETER UNLESS PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES AS AMENDED TO INCLUDE
TRANSLATORS AND INTERPRETERS I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. ONE ONE SIXTY
SIX. HELLO MY NAME IS RANDALL
MORGAN I AM A TRANSLATOR EDITOR
AND INTERPRETER OF RUSSIAN
FRENCH AND SPANISH OWNER OF
MORGAN LANGUAGE SERVICES AND
MEMBER OF THE A. L. C. GREAT
UNLESS PROFESSIONAL SERVICES AS
AMENDED TO INCLUDE TRANSLATORS
AND INTERPRETERS I OPPOSE. ONE
THIRTY. LINE. SEVENTY FIVE. ONE
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE GO TO LINE. THIRTY SEVEN.
ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS STEVEN FROM
AMERICA TRANSLATING SERVICES
OUR LAST THEY FELT IT I'M NOT
POSTING TO THE BILL UP FOR THE
SPANISH AND ALL THE MEN WHICH
IS THE CARPETING AND
TRANSLATING I AM A COPING.
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS YOU FOR
OPPOSITION. MISTER CHAIRMAN. WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
BILL THAT WOULD KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS AND EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT ESTIMATE
THE COST CAN BE ABSORBED WITHIN
EXISTING RESOURCES FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL I
WOULD NOTE THAT THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACTS DID PROVIDE
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS UP TO SEVENTEEN POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS EACH YEAR
FOR THREE YEARS. I DID EDG WITH
UP TO THREE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS EACH YEAR FOR THREE
YEARS. A TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROVISIONS OF EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY SEVEN. WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE WE'RE GOING TO GO ON
TO AB TWENTY THREE. FORTY FIVE
ON DENSITY BONUSES. AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION THERE'S NO ONE
HERE IN SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE IN SUPPORT
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
LINE ON THE PHONE LINES. WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE BY
MS GONZALEZ. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY FIVE. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEY PAD. AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. TO GET INTO THE
PHONE QUEUE THANK YOU. YOU ARE
WE HAVE ONE NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE EACH. IS
THIS REGARDING TWO TWO FIVE
SEVEN STILL NOW TWO TWO FIVE
SEVEN HAS HAS PASSED- THAT'S
WHAT I THOUGHT BUT I GET CALLS
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THE QUEUE OKAY. THE THIRD
OKAY. OF ANYWAY THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE
ARE ON SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY FIVE. AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE SIX ONE. THE SECURE
MEMBERS THIS IS BOB THE NAILER
REPRESENTING FEELS SEVEN
COMPANYIN ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS STRONGLY SUPPORT OF.
THE CALIFORNIA EVEN B. AND
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
AGAIN IF YOU ARE TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. THE NEW. I HAVE NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME PLEASE
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT WE'LL TAKE
OPPOSITION TO TWENTY THREE
FORTY FIVE THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE MODERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN OPPOSITION. TO TWENTY THREE
FORTY FIVE. IT AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AGAIN IT TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
TWO. PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE ONE
SIX TWO. YES I ACTUALLY OPPOSED
TO TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN I WAS
ONLINE BEFORE YOU- AND IT SO
I'M JUST GONNA OPPOSE. OKAY
THANK YOU.I THANK YOU WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY EIGHT LINE ONE EACH EACH
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. THIS IS RAY
LOWER BURKE FROM SIX TO NINE WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION OF. AB. TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE. WE HAVE LNE
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN
LINE ONE THREE SEVEN YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
SUSAN KERSHAWN CHAIR OF THE
NEXT THE NâNG CAMPAIGN
REPRESENTING THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS OPPOSED ABOUT
HOUSING POLICY WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL. MY NUMBER NINETY ONE LINE
NINE ONE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
FINALLY IN BROKEN COALITION FOR
SAN FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS IN
OPPOSITION. AND WHY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE NINE
ONE EIGHT NINE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
I AM FAHRZEUG RGM A TRANSLATOR
AND UNLOCKED PROFESSIONAL
CRITICISM AND Q. ALL RIGHT WE
ARE OFF OF THAT BILL. WE ARE ON
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE
ELECTRONS ARE WEIRD. SORRY
ABOUT THAT. EIGHT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
THE TELEPHONE KEY PAD. I HAVE
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT- FINANCED
YOU HAVE A FILE ON THE TWENTY
THREE FORTY FIVE. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THIS BILL THAT
WOULD KNOW THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES COSTS OF
THREE HUNDRED EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN THE
FIRST YEAR. AND ONE HUNDRED
NINETY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE
SECOND YEAR AND UP DATE DENSITY
BONUS LAW GUIDANCE TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE NOT REACH
TO PUBLISH ANNUAL PROGRESS
REPORT DOCUMENTS ONLINE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SEEING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE ABOUT
THE SUSPENSE. THAT CONCLUDES MS
GONZALEZ IS BILLS WILL MOVE ON
TO MR TANG. AB SIXTY NINE-
HERE'S WAY PRESENTATION AND ALL
OF HIS BILLS THANK YOU MR TANG-
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY NINE
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY
NINE. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTY NINE. GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIXTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF AB SIXTY
NINE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEY PAD WE HAVE LINE
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
FOR TWO. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DOESN'T MATTER
NOT LIKE HAS PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
B. AND HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIXTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. YEP NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHT WE'LL
TAKE OPPOSITION AB SIXTY NINE
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
ADDITIONALLY IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN OPPOSITION TO AB SIXTY
NINE. GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF THE E. B. SIXTY
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD
AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION.
OF AB SIXTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN IF ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE
QUEUING UP PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL
RIGHT BERMAN A FINANCIER OF A
FILE ON AB SIXTY NINE. YES
THANK YOU AT THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE ESTIMATES
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE ONE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THREE YEARS AND SEVEN HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
ON GOING. TO ESTABLISH AND
ADMINISTER THE STATE PROGRAM.
CALIPHATE CAL HFA ESTIMATES
WILL REQUIRE BETWEEN FORTY
THREE POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
AND SIXTY THREE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TO ADMINISTER
THE ACCOUNT ISSUE REVENUE BONDS
AND HIGHER OUTSIDE BOND
COUNSEL. IN FINANCE PROGRAM OF
LASTLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES COST ONE
HUNDRED HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THE FIRST YEAR AND-
AND NINETY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONGOING. THANK YOU.
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIXTY NINE GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVE ON AB EIGHT
FORTY ONE SCHOOL ENERGY
EFFICIENCY STIMULUS PROGRAM.
WILL TAKE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY HERE. THERE'S NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE IS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT FORTY ONE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHT FOUR ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
FOUR ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
IN JUST A MOMENT WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEIR LINE NUMBER THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETY SEVEN NINE ONE NINE
SEVEN YOU MAY GO AHEAD. WE HAD
LINE ONE NINE SEVEN THE LINE IS
OPEN. I AM BE TREATED ANY LESS
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES IS A MAN
BETWEEN TO THE TRANSLATORS AND
INTERPRETERS ARE YOU OPPOSED I
AM A PROFESSIONAL TRANSLATOR
THANK YOU. OKAY IF ANYONE IS
WAITING ON LINE TO SPEAK ON
THE- TWENTY FIVE FIFTY SEVEN WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE BUSINESS OF
THAT YOU CAN SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS THROUGH THE SENATE-
WEBSITE. SO PLEASE DO THAT BUT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE TAKING
ANYMORE TESTIMONY ON THAT BILL
WE'RE ON AB EIGHT FORTY ONE AT
THE MOMENT. IF ANYONE IS IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHT FOUR ONE BY
MISTER CHANGED. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
FOUR ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEY PAD
AGAIN TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF
AB EIGHT FOUR ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. NO ONE IN THE
PHONE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
OKAY WE'LL TAKE OPPOSITION
EIGHT FOUR ONE THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ONTHE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB EIGHT FORTY ONE. WE
DO HAVE SOMEONE IN THE QUEUE
WERE AT JUST GETTING THERE
GIVING DOWN THEIR NUMBER ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. LINE EIGHTY FIVE
WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU
LINE EAT FIVE. YOUR TURN NUMBER
THERE ARE NO MORE WEAPONS THAN
THE MILITANCY AND DEMAND
MANAGEMENT COUNCIL WE ARE
OPPOSED. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AGAIN F YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
EIGHT FORTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
NINE ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY
LINE ONE NINE ZERO YOU MAY GO
AHEAD THE LINE IS OPEN. MORNING
MEMBERS RICHARD MARCUSSEN ON
BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED TO THE
POLICY. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT FOUR ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
THE TELEPHONE KEY PAD ONE THEN.
ZERO YEAH NO ONE QUEUING UP
PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YOU HAVE
A FILE ON EIGHT FOUR ONE. THANK
YOU AT THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION ESTIMATES THE
PROGRAM COULD RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL COST OF FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY- THAT WOULD BE BORNE
BY RATEPAYERS RECEIVE ELECTRIC
SERVICE AN ELECTRIC INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITY TERRITORY.
ADDITIONALLY THE PC INDICATES
OR REQUIRE TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE
PC UTILITIES REIMBURSEMENT
ACCOUNT OF TO MONITOR THE NEW
ENERGY EFFICIENCY. EFFICIENCY
PROGRAM AND TO CREATE A
RECORDING TOOL TO TRACK LEVY
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION ESTIMATES THE
BILL WILL COST SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE ENERGY
RESOURCES PROGRAM ACCOUNT OR OR
A AND YOUR ONE AND SIX POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING-
AND WE WOULD NOTE THAT-
ALTHOUGH FUNDING SOURCES AND
SPECIFIED BY THE BILL. OF THE
ENERGY COMMISSION'S PRIMARY
OPERATING FUND IS CIRCA- WHICH
IS IN A STRUCTURAL DEFICIT. SO
ANY INCREASE IN EXPENDITURES
WILL EXACERBATE THE FISCAL
STRAIN ON THE ACCOUNT- A LIKELY
ACCELERATE- ANY NEED FOR A FEE
INCREASE. LASTLY THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD ESTIMATES COST
OF THREE HUNDRED NINETY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE COST
OF IMPLEMENTATION ACCOUNT IN
TWENTY. TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND ONE HUNDRED NINETY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GROWING.
THANK YOU SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FORTY ONE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING TO
MR MCCARTY SPILLS HIS WAY
PRESENTATION ON BOTH- AB ONE
TWENTY FIVE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT. THERE'S
NOBODY IN ONE TWELVE IN SUPPORT
SURE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT OF AB. ONE TWENTY
FIVE. PLEASE AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB ONE TWENTY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE TWENTY FIVE PRESS ONE
THEN IF ZERO AND PLEASE CAN
FIND YOUR TESTIMONY TO YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION. IN JUST A MOMENT
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT. IN ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETY ONE YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. NINE ONE NINE ONE.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS SAM ASHER
WITH THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION- WE ARE
STORED. THANK YOU. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
TWENTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHT IF
YOU'RE HERE TO OPPOSE AB ONE
TWENTY FIVE- NOW IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITY THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE TELEPHONE LINE
WISHING TO OPPOSE AB ONE TWENTY
FIVE. NOW IS YOUR TIME. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB ONE TWENTY FIVE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE AB ONE TWENTY
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN.
ZERO JUST A MOMENT THANK YOU. I
HAVE SEVERAL IN THE QUEUE. BY
NUMBER NINETY NINE NINE ZERO
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS NOT IN
OPPOSITION ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT
OF AB ONE TWENTY FIVE ON BEHALF
OF THE SITTING COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCANS PAUL YODER THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING. AND AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH- TO OPPOSE. AB ONE TWENTY
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND ONE NINE TWO ZERO
ONE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE TWO HUNDRED AND ONE.
THE LINE IS OPEN. ON JULY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE. TWO ZERO
THREE. THANK YOU OH THREE WE
HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU.
HELLO YES PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
TWO ZERO THREE. OKAY. NINE TWO
ZERO THREE YOU MAY GO AHEAD AND
SPEAK. OKAY I SUPPORT YEAH
CONNIE OF INTERPRETERS AND
TRANSLATORS. NOT BE EMPLOYEES.
THANK YOU. IT IS A GENTLEMAN
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO- OPPOSE AB
ONE TWENTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN TO OPPOSE
AB ONE TWENTY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO THE LAST.
I HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE CORRECT IS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVE A
FILE ON AB ONE TWENTY FIVE.
SHARE A YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE AS THE BILL
CREATES COST PRESSURES IN THE
HIGH HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS TO
LOW BILLIONS OF NOT PROPOSITION
NINETY GENERAL FUND AND
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND- AND ALTHOUGH
THESE COSTS WOULD BE DEPENDENT
UPON AN APPROPRIATION IN THE
BUDGET ACT- THE PANDEMIC IS
NEEDED INCREASINGLY UNLIKELY
THAT THE STATE CAN SUPPORT SUCH
A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
ONGOING GENERAL FUND
APPLICATIONS. ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL CREATES COSTELLO MILLIONS
NON PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION TO DEVELOP THE
PLAN AND IMPLEMENTING FORMULA.
LASTLY I WOULD KNOW THAT THE
BILL PRESUPPOSES
RECOMMENDATIONS ANTICIPATED TO
BE INCLUDED IN THE MASTER PLAN
FOR EARLY LEARNING AND CARE
THAT IS ANTICIPATED TO BE
RELEASED IN OCTOBER. OF THIS
YEAR. THANK YOU. THEY YOU. SEE
NO GO UP WITH OPPOSITE. AB ONE
TWENTY FIVE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY TWO MISTER MCCARTY
ON PAROLE- THERE'S NO ONE HERE
IN SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE IN SUPPORT IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY TWO. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO THREE FOUR
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. MY NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE SIX SEVEN.
SJCAM MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
QUALITY CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. YOU HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE ALL
RIGHT IS THERE OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO NOW IS
YOUR TIME THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM. THERE'S NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE SIR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME. YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
THANK YOU. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN%
IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY TWO. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSEAB TWENTY THREE FORTY
TWO. PRESS ONE THEN IF. ZERO NO
ONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. R. I. DEPARTMENT
FINANCE YOU HAVE A FILE. YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE I WOULD
NOTE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION ESTIMATES
INITIAL ONE TIME COST OF
APPROXIMATELY NINETY ABOUT
NINETY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND DECLINING TO
ROUGHLY HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING. ON
WITH NO CITIES YEAR ANTICIPATES
AN INDUSTRY NATIONAL SURGEON
WORKLOAD TO APPLY CREDITS TO
CURRENT PAROLEES UNDER THE
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS IS
ALREADY RECEIVING RETROACTIVE
CREDITS- THESE ADDITIONAL COSTS
ARE UNKNOWN- AND CAN'T BE
QUANTIFIED INTO THE CREDITS ARE
ORDERED AND IT'S DETERMINED HOW
MANY PAROLEES ARE IMMEDIATELY
DUE FOR REVIEW. BY THE BOARD
ADDITIONALLY CDCR A CURRENTLY
UTILIZES AND EARNED DISCHARGE
POLICY THAT INCENTIVIZES GOOD
BEHAVIOR AND RE INTEGRATE OF
CREDITS. REINTEGRATE EFFORTS.
THROUGH REDUCED A PROVISION AND
GIVEN THAT MANY OF THE PAROLEES
WHO WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR EARLY
DISCHARGE UNDER THIS BILL. MAY
ALREADY BE ELIGIBLE FOR REDUCED
GIRL TERMS UNDER EXISTING
POLITY POLICY- THIS BILL MAY
NOT RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
SAVINGS. LASTLY THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE ESTIMATES ONE TIME
COST OF ONE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND. AND FIVE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ARE BETWEEN TWENTY
TWENTY AND TWENTY FOUR.
ACCORDING TO. TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE AN
ONGOING. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY TWO WILL GO O
SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO MISTER
SANTIAGO'S BILLS HE'S WAY
PRESENTATION ON ALL OF THEM AB
TWO THREE EIGHT HIS FIRST STOP
ON UNLICENSED CRANHAM MOBILES
DISMANTLING THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT NOW IS THE
TIME FOR SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM ONE TWELVE IN
SUPPORT IS THERE ANYONE ONLINE.
IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWO THREE
EIGHT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO THREE EIGHT. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
THREE EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO LINE NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE NINE SIX
THE LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS GAVIN
MCCUE WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE DISMANTLED
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
FIVE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
THREE EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THAT
MEANS. EVERYONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT NOW
IS THE TIME OPPOSITION AB TWO
THREE EIGHT- THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO TWO THREE
EIGHT THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE OPPOSED TO TWO THREE
EIGHT. IS THERE ANYONE ON TE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO AB TWO
THREE EIGHT. SEVEN IF YOU WISH
TO OPPOSE A. B. TWO THREE EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO OPPOSE A. B. TWO
THREE EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. SO I HAVE NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE R. I.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVE A
FILE ON A B. TWO THREE EIGHT
WHILE MISTER CHAIR YES WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE WHICH
ONE WOULD NOTE THAT ACCORDING
TO THE DEPARTMENT SHOULD
CONTINUE TO BE A PART OF THE
STRIKE FORCE THE BILL WOULD
RESULT IN A NEED- FOR MORE THAN
ONE MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR
THROUGH THE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
SUNSET DATE. IDEA VS COST THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO SIX
HUNDRED NINETEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE AND THREE HUNDRED
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR ADDITIONALLY
THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL ESTIMATES
COST OF SEVEN HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT. FOR THESE
ACTIVITIES. ALL RIGHT SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP AB TWO THREE EIGHT
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE WITHOUT
OBJECTION MOVING TO AB EIGHT TO
SIX. ON EMERGENCY FOOD
ASSISTANCE THE SUPPORT TIME
THERE'S NO ONE HERE THERE'S NO
ONE IN ONE TWELVE MISTER
MODERATOR MRS MODERATOR MS
MODERATOR. IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE. IN SUPPORT OF
AB. EIGHT TO SIX. IF YOU WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
EIGHT TWO SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. THE MOMENT PLEASE.
THANK TWO HUNDRED AND SEVEN
POINT TWO ZERO SEVEN HE MAY GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS SHANTI PRASAD
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FOOD BANKS WE ARE VERY PROUD TO
CO SPONSOR EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY
SIX AND ON BEHALF OF OUR FORTY
TWO MEMBERS ACROSS THE STATE WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. AND ALSO
VOICING THE STRONG SUPPORT FOR
CALIFORNIA HUNGER ACTION
COALITION IN A MULTI
STAKEHOLDER COALITION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IF YOU ARE A
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB H.
TWO SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE NOW IS
THE TIME FOR OPPOSITION OF TWO
EIGHT TWO SIX THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. MMHM MODERATOR
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHT
TO SIX. IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE
A. B. EIGHT TO SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE A. B. EIGHT TWO SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO.
I JUST MOMENT PLEASE WE HAVE
SOMEONE KEEPING UP. NINE TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN LINE TWO
ONE SIX. PLEASE GO AHEAD THE
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS ISABEL
ROMERO I AM A MEDICAL
INTERPRETER UNLESS PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES AMENDED TO INCLUDE
TRANSLATOR AND INTERPRETER I
CALLED. ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WE ARE ON E.
B. EIGHT TWO SIX IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE A. B. EIGHT TWO SIX. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. NO ONE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE.
BERMAN FINANCIAL FILING AB
EIGHT TO SIX. THANK YOU WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE AS IT
MAY RESULT IN GENERAL FUND
PRESSURES IN THE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OR MORE PER MONTH. IN
BENEFITS DEPENDING ON THE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY
APPLY FOR AND RECEIVE BENEFITS
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL RESULT IN
UNKNOWN BUT POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND
PRESSURE TO ADMINISTER FOOD
ASSISTANCE STATEWIDE. FINALLY
THIS BILL MAY REQUIRE
AUTOMATION CHANGES TO EXISTING
SYSTEMS INTERNETPROGRAMMING
EFFORTS WHICH MAY RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL AND NO GENERAL FUND
PRESSURES. ALL RIGHT SING NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB EIGHT TO SIX. WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. DURING TWO AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTEEN MISTER SANTIAGO
TRANSGENDER WELLNESS IN EQUITY.
SEEING NO ONE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT SAYING NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE IN SUPPORT IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN. IF YOU ARE IN
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO WINDS
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE SIX SEVEN. JENNY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. IF YOU
ARE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO I HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE NOW IS THE TIME FOR
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE- MODERATOR IF THERE'S
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN NOW IS THE TIME.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
THANK YOU. IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AGAIN TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN. ZERO I HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHT
FOR ME TO. IN THE FINAL. YES
THANK YOU WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE- BECAUSE IT WOULD
LIKELY RESULT IN GENERAL FUND
IMPACTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT. I
WOULD NOTE THAT THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE COST PRESSURES TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH A
POTENTIALLY ABOUT A LITTLE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL STAFFING RESOURCES
IN CONTRACTORS. ARE NEEDED FOR
THIS. PROGRAM ALL RIGHT SEEING
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN. WE'LL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING AB TWENTY
SIX NINETY NINE ALSO BY MR
SANTIAGO. ON FIREARMS. IT'S
TIME FOR SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY SIX
NINETY NINE. IF YOU ARE I
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SIX NINETY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO YES
ONE MOMENT. SOME MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED LINE TO. GO AHEAD.
RESEARCHER MEMBERS MATTHEW SO I
REALLY GOING TO HAPPEN ARMS
RECREATION AND CONSERVATION
AUTHORITY I'D SUPPORT THANK YOU.
IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SIX NINE NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. IF
I HAVE A HAMMER OR. YOU HAVE NO
ONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT NOW IS THE
TIME FOR OPPOSITION OF TWENTY
SIX NINETY NINE- ISN'T THERE'S
NO ONE IN THIS ROOM OPPOSE
THERE'S NO MONEY IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO TWENTY
SIX NINETY NINE. PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION.
AND YOUR POSITION. IF YOU WISH
TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN.
ZERO THE C. SCORE YEAH. I HAVE
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE TO OPPOSE
AB TWO SIX NINE NINE THANK YOU-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I DON'T
HAVE A FILE ON THIS MEASURE NO
FILE NO HANDS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
NINE WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ONTO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO WHO HAS ALSO WAIVED
PRESENTATION. I HAD- I'M GOING
TO DO A REMINDER BEFORE WE DO
THAT FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. OUR PHONE
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SIX NINE EIGHT
FOUR FIVE NINE TWO. AGAIN PHONE
NUMBER. 844-291-6364 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SIX NINE EIGHT
FOUR FIVE NINE TWO. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS YOU
CAN GO TO THE SENATE FOR THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC OMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO. FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE FOLLOW THE
MODERATORS INSTRUCTIONS PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR THE OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE KEY OR THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER AT THE TIME YOU
WILL BE ON MUTED AND YOU WILL
BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE AND FOR
ALL IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE YOUR
DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON. PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT AND WE WANT TO HEAR
FROM YOU CLEARLY SO PLEASE TRY
TO FOLLOW THOSE INSTRUCTIONS.
WITH THAT WE WILL GO TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO WHO IS
WAY PRESENTATION. ON AB THREE
TO THREE FOR NEWSPAPER WORKER
STATUS. THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM IN SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE IN SUPPORT.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE TWO THREE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE TWO
THREE. PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
THE TELEPHONE KEY PAD. IF YOU
ARE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE TWO THREE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. OKAY
THE MOST GOOD. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THREE LINE TWO TO THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I'M KAREN ANDERSON
AND I'M THE FOUNDER OF THE
FREELANCERS AGAIN EIGHTY FIVE
AND I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
AB. THREE TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU. THEY HAVE. IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHT WE'LL
GO TO OPPOSITION TO AB THREE
TWO THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN ONE
TWELVE IS OR ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINES. MODERATOR OPPOSED
AB THREE TWO THREE. IF YOU WISH
TO OPPOSE AB THREE TWO THREE
PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO. AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB. THREE
TWENTY THREE PRESS ONE THEN IF
ZERO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NINE
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
NINE TWO TWO EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KRAMER MY WOBURN ON THE
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES IN THE
AMENDED TO INCLUDE TRANSLATORS
AND INTERPRETERS I CODES. AND
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB
THREE TWENTY THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO GIVE LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE TWO ONE
SIX. OUR MARROW MEDICAL
INTERPRETER UNLESS PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES AS AMENDED TO INCLUDE
TRANSLATOR AND INTERPRETER I
OPPOSE I AM A MEMBER OF COPTIC.
YOU HAVE MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY EACH LINE TWO TWO
EIGHT YOU MAY GO AHEAD. I AM
NOT AMONG WAS LEARNED A MEDICAL
INTERPRETER UNLESS PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES IN DOMESTIC TWENTY
TRANSLATORS AND INTERPRETERS
ARE YOU CLOSE. AS A REMINDER IF
YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB. THREE
TWENTY THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE TWO TWO EIGHT. I
AM NORMAL NINE POLITICAL
INTERPRETER UNLESS PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES ENVIRONMENT TO INCLUDE
TRANSLATORS AND INTERPRETERS I
OPPOSE. WE HAVE MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN LINE TWO
ONE EACH YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE TWO ONE
EIGHT TO EIGHTEEN WE HAVE THE
LINE OPEN. HELLO I AM PAMELA
FITCH LAWRENCE CERTIFIED
MEDICAL INTERPRETER ALLEGED
SURFICIAL SERVICES IS AMENDED
TO INCLUDE TRANSLATORS AND
INTERPRETERS. I OPPOSE. MY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FOUR AT LINE TWO THREE FOUR YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. THANK YOU I AM
PERFECT YEP GO HEAD. YEAH I
NINE THIRTY THAT'D BE ACT CORD
THIRTY INTERPRETER LED
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES IS
AMENDED TO INCLUDE TRANSLATORS
AND INTERPRETERS I OPPOSE. I
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY
THREE LINE ONE NINE THREE YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. I AM CERTIFIED
MEDICAL INTERPRETER SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA AND UNLESS THE SB
TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN IS AMENDED
TO INCLUDE PROFESSIONAL
INTERPRETERS AND TRANSLATORS.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE A. B. THREE TWO
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AGAIN THAT IS TO OPPOSE E.
B. THREE TWO THREE NINE TWO
HUNDRED AND TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE. TWO ONE ZERO. I'M
SORRY I WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT
IN FACT THAT I'M IN THE WRONG
PLACE. GO AHEAD. JOINT PATRICK
IS AT SEVEN MY NAME IS BILL
LAWRENCE I'M A PROFESSIONAL
JAPANESE TECHNICAL TRANSLATOR.
ADDITIONAL SERVICES MENDOCINE
TRANSLATORS INTERPRETERS I
OPPOSE. AND IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB THREE TWO THREE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN
THAT IS TO OPPOSE AB. THREE TWO
THREE. I HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION OF AB
THREE TWO THREE PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU FINANCED YOU HAVE ON
FILE. S. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I WOULD NOT THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES ESTIMATES
COSTS OF ONE HUNDRED FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING TO
IMPLEMENT THE ON GOING
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS OF THE
BILL. ONLY BUT NOT THAT EDT
STILL DEVELOPING THEIR COSTS
JUST MEANT. BUT WE WOULD NOT
THE COST MAY BE OBSERVABLE-
GIVEN THE RESOURCES PROVIDED.
TO THEM IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT THANK YOU. SHE NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB THREE TWO THREE. WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING TO MISTER
MURATSUCHI. HE HAS TWO BILLS
HE'S WAY PRESENTATION ON BOTH.
MAYBE THREE TO SIX NOW IS THE
TIME FOR. TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
THERE'S ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
TWENTY SIX. IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
TWENTY SIX. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN IF ZERO. AGAIN TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE TWO SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. NO
ONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT NOW IS THE
TIME PROPOSITION THERE'S NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED IS THERE
ANYONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE NO
SIR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO AB THREE TO SIX
OPPOSITION TO AB THREE TWO SIX.
SAY YOUR NAME. YOUR POSITION
AND YOUR EMPLOYMENT. IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE AB THREE TWENTY
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN.
ZERO NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY NINE TWO THREE ZERO YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR JOHN
MOFFETT ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE FOR AUTOMOTIVE
INNOVATION IN OPPOSITION. IF
YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB THREE
TWENTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE IS THERE
FILE ON THIS BILL FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION BUT WE KNOW
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES ESTIMATES ONE TIME
COST OFTWO HUNDRED NINETY
THREE DOLLARS FROM THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT. AT UPDATE
THEIR NETWORK DATABASE SYSTEMS
BUT I WAS NOT THAT THE- ONGOING
COST ESTIMATED TO BE MINOR
OBSERVABLE. ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL INCLUDES PROVISIONS THAT
ALLOW DMV TO CHARGE FEES TO
RECOVER THEIR COSTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SEE NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB THREE
TWENTY SIX. WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING TO AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY TWO. ON COSMETIC
SAFETY. NOW IS THE TIME FOR
SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO. IF YOU
ARE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN IF
YOU ARE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF AB. TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I
HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE RIGHT NOW IS THE TIME
FOR OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY TWO THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOTHING
ONE TWELVE MODERATORS ANYONE
ONLINE ON THE PHONE LINE. IN
OPPOSITION OF TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY TWO. IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
TWO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN
TO OPPOSE AB. TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY TWO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
I HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL RIGHTS-
FINANCE DO YOU HAVE A FILE ON
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO. S.
THANK YOU THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ESTIMATES GENERAL
FUND COST OF SEVEN HUNDRED
FORTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
THE FIRST YEAR OF
IMPLEMENTATION AND
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER. A JUSTICE ESTIMATES
COSTA TWO HUNDRED NINETEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE FIRST
YEAR. AND THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER. AND THEN WHAT WE
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THE COST
STATED ABOVE ONE OF CURRENT
TILL FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE. I DO TO THE
BILL'S IMPLEMENTATION ON
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. THANK YOU USING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO WILL GO
TO SUSPEND STUFF MOVING TO
MISTER DAILY IS WAY
PRESENTATION ON A. B. FOR THREE
FOUR. HOURS THE TIME FOR
SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM IN SUPPORT NOBODY IN ONE
TWELVE. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOUR THIRTY FOUR. IF YOU WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOUR THREE FOUR. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF AB FOUR THREE
FOUR. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED. AND THIRTY SEVEN NINE
TWO THREE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF COLD WATER ON BEHALF
OF THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. BY
NUMBER FORTY TWO LINE FOUR TWO
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
JERRY MEMBERS OF THE MATTER ON
BEHALF OF HABITAT HUMANITY.
WORKING WITH THE SPONSORS OF
THE BELL ON A FEW AMENDMENTS
AND HIS A FULL SUPPORT POSITION
AT THAT TIME THANK YOU. I
NUMBER NINETY NINE NINE ZERO
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. IF YOU CAN
REMEMBER SPOILER BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY SHERIFF'S IS
GOING TO SUPPORT THANKS. IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB FOUR THREE FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO EVERYONE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
ALL RIGHT NOW IS THE TIME FOR
OPPOSITION AB FOUR THIRTY FOUR-
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOTHING IN ONE TWELVE
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION TO FOUR
THREE FOUR. IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB FOUR THREE FOUR.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE. AB
FOUR THREE FOUR PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL
RIGHT SO WE'VE DONE SUPPORT FOR
ANY OPPOSITION I'M SORRY.
PLEASE STAND UP PAGE TO. FACE
TWO I HAVE STILL HAD A PHD YOU
GUYS HAVE A DIFFERENT PAGE
LAYOUT THE BIKE WITH RIGHT A
MODERATE THERE FIVE SHOULD ME
HALF THEIR FILE. FOUR THREE
FOUR. YES THEY YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE'RE OPPOSED THIS MEASURE.
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT HOUSING
DOES DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES
COSTA TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN FIRST
YEAR. AND ONE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE SECOND YEAR. OF
THE UPDATE GUIDELINES ALIGN
PROGRAMS SCREENING APPLICATIONS
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND ACQUIRE A NEW ONLINE PORTAL
TO MANAGE CENTRALIZED IN THE
DESIGN PROGRAMS. I SEE NO HANDS
GO IN IN EARNEST. TO TURN THE
PAGE- WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FOUR
THREE FOUR WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING TO MS AGUILAR CURRY'S
BILL SHE HAS WAIVED.
PRESENTATION AND WE'RE GOING AB
FIVE SEVEN ZERO ON. CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND IT'S
TIME FOR SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE
HERE THERE'S NO ONE IN ONE
TWELVE MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIVE SEVEN ZERO. IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
SEVEN ZERO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AGAIN TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF AB FIVE SEVEN ZERO.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
THE PHONE KEYPAD. I NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE LINE
TWO THREE THREE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS DANIEL KESSLER
CARTER ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
AS WELL AS COMMON SENSE KIDS
ACTION WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED ON THE
STYLE. IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE SEVEN
ZERO YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD. I
HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT NOW IS THE
TIME FOR OPPOSITION. SEE NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM NO ONE IN ONE
TWELVE IS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE. IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
FIVE SEVEN ZERO. IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB FIVE SEVEN ZERO YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO ON
THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AND IF
YOU WISH TO OPPOSE. AB FIVE
SEVEN ZERO. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE PHONE KEYPAD.
I HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YOU HAVE
A FILE. THANK YOU I WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THIS BILL
THAT WOULD KNOW THAT THE PUBLIC
UTLITIES COMMISSION ESTIMATES
TWO POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR EACH UNDERTAKE THE
OVERSIGHT AND EXPANSION OF THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND PROGRAM AS ENVISIONED BY
THE SPELL. WE WOULD KNOW THAT
EXTENDING THE PROGRAM WILL
RESULT IN CONTINUED PIERCY
STATE OPERATION COSTS AT
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. AN ADDITIONAL
EXTENDED THE COLLECTION OF
SURCHARGE REVENUE MAY RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL COLLECTIONS OF UP TO
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR RATE PAYERS. LASTLY THE OF
PLANT RESEARCH INDICATES TO THE
RECORD. TO STREAMLINE LOCAL
PERMITTING FOR BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE WOULD REQUIRE
TWO HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A GENERAL FUND- FOR A
ONE TIME CONSULTING COSTS. AND
TO EARN FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
ON GOING- FOR RESOURCES. SHE NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB FIVE SEVENTY GOES TO
SUSPENSE MOVING AB TWENTY ONE
OH SIX. ON WILDFIRE AND HABITAT
AND NESTING- TIME FOR SUPPORT
THERE'S NO ONE HERE NO ONE IN
ONE TWELVE IS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWENTY ONE OH SIX. HE'S AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
ONE OH SIX. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE OH
SIX. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN.
ZERO MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE LINE TWO FOUR FIVE
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. YEAH HI
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE IT'S
MARK WITH WATERFOWL WITH THIS-
BILL AB TWENTY ONE SPIT THAT
TWENTY ONE OF THE BEFORE YOU
CAN IS A DEL BOND IN. CAR
PROGRAM IN THE FISH GAME. IT'S
SUPPORTS BUT WHY AND FARMERS BY
INCREMENTALLY INCREASE ENERGY
BIRDS THE- REVENUE GENERATED BY
THE SEA GOOD ALL BE USED AS A
MAY FOR CONSERVE PER. LEVERJ
MORE FEDERAL DOLLARS FOR. WE
ARE SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER TO HER AND FOURTEEN TO
FORCE THE- YOU MAKE AHEAD.
RICHARD SHERMAN MEMBERS ARE
AGREEMENT ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION ARE THOUSANDS OF
MEMBERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE OH SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN. ZERO ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. YOU HAVE MY NUMBER
EIGHTY THAT FLYING EIGHT ZERO
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HI MR THIS
TIMID MAN I'M THE CHAIR OF THE
SACRAMENTO SOUTH SACRAMENTO. A
OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
DISASSOCIATION AND ANNERY
MEMBER IN STRONG SUPPORT. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE OH SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO WE
HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT NOW IS THE
TIME PROPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
IN THE ROOM OPPOSERS NOBODY IN
ONE TWELVE OPPOSES MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
OPPOSED AB TWENTY ONE OH SIX.
IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY
ONE OH SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB TWENTY ONE OH SIX.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO
THERE IS NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHT
FINANCING OF A FINAL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OF WITH A NOTE
THAT WE ESTIMATE THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD. IN HER COST
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM
THE NESTING BIRD HABITAT
INCENTIVE PROGRAM ACCOUNT.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
THREE HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING. BUT
OCCASIONALLY NOTE THAT- THE NEW
FEES IMPOSED BY THE BILL RSG TO
MAY RESULT IN A REVENUES OF
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY. THANK
YOU SEEN HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWENTY ONE OH SIX
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING TO
AB MISTER COOPER AB SIX SIX
FOUR ON WORKERS COMPENSATION
HE'S WAY PRESENTATION. ABOUT
THE TIME FOR SUPPORT THERE'S NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM NOBODY'S ONE
TWELVE IS THERE ANYONE. ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SIX SIX FOUR. PLEASE ENTER IF
YOU WERE TO TELL IN FOR OF AB
SIX SIX FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AGAIN TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF AB SIX SIX FOUR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
NINE NINE TWO FOUR NINE YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS HERE AND READ
REPRESENTING PORAC CAL FIGHTER
AND HIGHWAY PATROL ASSOCIATION
ON STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. SIX
SIX FOUR. NEXT WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND. THIRTY
NINE NINE TWO THREE NINE. YES
THIS IS JOHN MOBILE ON THE APP
THE CALIFORNIA OFFICERS. BOB
COALITION THE PUBLIC SAFETY.
OFFICERS SYSTEMS HELP ONE
CALLER AND UNIVERSITY CHIEF
ASSOCIATION. CALIFORNIA SINCE
OF IN ON. FUNGUS AWAY QUITE. IN
THE- TRADE SPACE CO. ALMOND
STRONG'S. FOR SIX FOUR. WE HAVE
MY NUMBER FOR LINE FIVE FOR YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS MY
EAGLE REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. TWO HUNDRED LINE TWO
ZERO ZERO YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
MISTER TRIMMERS MATTHEW
CYBERLINK I MEAN HALF THE LOS
ANGELES WITH PROTECTIVE LEAGUE
AND ASSOCIATION A LOT ANGELES
DERBYSHIRE BOTH IN STRONG THANK
YOU. AS A REMINDER IF YOU WISH
TO. IN SOME. OF AB SIX SIX FOUR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT IS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF AB SIX SIX FOUR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. ARE WE HAVE NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT YOU MAY
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT NOW IS THE
TIME FOR OPPOSITION OF AB SIX
SIX FOUR THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSE THERE'S NOBODY IN
ONE TWELVE. MODERATORS ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB
SIX SIX FOUR. HE WISHED TO
OPPOSE A. B. SIX SIX FOUR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO. MY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SIX LINE TWO FIVE SIX YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. MORE MATURE MEMBERS
RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE
RESEARCHERS OF PATIENT SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE A. B. SIX SIX FOUR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN. ZERO I
HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE TO
OPPOSE AB SIX SIX FOUR YOU MAY
CONTINUE THANK YOU FINANCED THE
OF A FILE. THANK YOU WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THIS BILL-
BUT WHEN AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS ESTIMATES
OF THE OVERALL FISCAL IMPACT OF
THIS BILL IS UNKNOWN. BUT AT A
MINIMUM- THE FISCAL IS
ESTIMATED AT FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS INITIALLY AND
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
FROM THE WORKERS COMPENSATION
ADMINISTRATION REVOLVING FUND.
ADDITIONALLY VARIOUS OTHER
STATE AGENCIES INCLUDING CAL
FIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS A REPORT UNKNOWN A
GENERAL FUND COSTS ASSOCIATED.
WITH INCREASED CLAIMS. THANK
YOU AND GOD BLESS YOU. A SINGLE
CANS GO UP WITHOUT A- AB SIX
SIX FOUR WITH US. MOVING TO
MISTER GRAYSON ABC SIX SEVENTY
WAY PRESS. TIME FIRST. THE NO
ONE IN THE ROOM AND SUPPORT
THERE'S NO ONE IN ONE TWELVE
AND SUPPORTERS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE. IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN VICTIMS
COMPENSATION. AND USE OF EXACT
EXCESSIVE FORCE. WITH. AND
AGAIN ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK AT THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS
ONE NINE ZERO PRESS. ONE ZERO
LINED TWO FOUR EIGHT. TWO FOUR
EIGHT ONE IS OPEN. HI THAT SAID
THAT BY UNIONS ON THE POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE AFTER
RECIDIVISM COALITION CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF BABY OF THIS
BILL. PICTURE NO ONE ELSE INTO
IT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT NOW IS
THE PROPER THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSE THERE'S NO ONE
IN. ROOM ONE TWELVE IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION OF. SEVEN SIX SEVEN.
WE WISH TO SPEAK IN A POSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO A
TEACHER THERE IS NO ONE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU THE VICTIM
COMPENSATION BOARD ESTIMATES
THE BILL WOULD RESULT IN ANNUAL
COSTS APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
RESTITUTION FUND DUE TO THE
EXPANSION OF THE PROGRAM
ADDITIONALLY A BECAUSE THE
BILL'S LANGUAGE DOES NOT LIMIT
CLAIMS TO INSIST INCIDENCES
THAT OCCUR POST ENACTMENT OF
THE BOARD ESTIMATES A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF CLAIMS
FOR THE PAST SEVEN YEARS MAYBE
SUBMITTED. WHICH COULD RESULT
IN COST OF APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ON A ONE TIME
BASIS. I WOULD KNOW THAT THE
RESTITUTION FUND IS JEFF. WOULD
NOT ABLE TO SERVE THE
ADDITIONAL COSTS. US SO
THEREFORE THIS BILL RESULTS IN
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES. LASTLY THE BOARD
RECEIVED A 60% REIMBURSEMENT
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT-
THE VICTIMS OF CRIME ACT. OF
WHICH CURRENTLY AMOUNTS TO
ABOUT TWENTY FOUR POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS. AT THIS TIME
IT'S AT A IF BILL WOULD BY. THE
RULES POTENTIALLY PUTTING
GENERAL FUND AT RISK. THANK YOU
SEE NO HAN GO UP WITHOUT OF AB
SEVENTY OF. GODDESSES MYSTERY
HOLDEN BILL HE HAS PLAYED
PRISON I ALL THREE. AB NINE
SEVEN. NOW IS THE TIME ZONE
CORPS FOR OF DIRECTORS NOW IS
THE FOR SO. THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM NO ONE IN ONE TWELVE
IS THERE ANYWAY ON THE PHONE
LINES IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE
SEVEN NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS. SURE THERE'S NO
ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT NOW IS THE
TIME FOR OPPOSITION THERE'S NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM OPPOSE THERE'S
NO ONE ONE TWELVE SO ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB. NINE
SEVEN NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE
WAS NO ONE EIGHT TWO MISTER
TURNER. ALL RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. HE WAS CHAIR WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE- WELL A
FINALIZED JUST LAST NIGHT AND
WAS UNAVAILABLE THE TIME OF
THIS ANALYSIS WE NOTE OUR
INITIAL ESTIMATE IS THAT THE
SECRETARY OF STATE- REQUIRED TO
STAFF AT A COST. OF THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND IT IS AND
WHETHER IT WOULD BE THE GENERAL
FUND BUSINESS SHE'S FUND OR
COMBINATION OF BOTH THAT WOULD
SUPPORT THOSE COSTS. ALL RIGHTS
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB NINE SEVEN NINE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. A. B. TEN
TWENTY TWO ON PEACE OFFICER USE
OF FORCE- NOW IS THE TIME FOR
SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NO ONE IN ONE
TWELVE. IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TEN TWENTY TWO. AND AGAIN WITH
HIS INTERMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
MIN ZERO YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF TEN TWENTY TWO. WE
DO HAVE SOMEONE INTO. GOING TO
GO TO LINE SIXTY SEVEN ONE
SIXTY SEVEN OF ONE IS OPEN.
MARTIN ON THE OF THE BODY CAL
AND FORT. AND WILL NOW GO TO
LINE. ONE ZERO. MISTER CHAIRMAN
GENTLY ON COUNCILMEMBER CITY OF
CLAREMONT IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR THERE
IS NO ONE ELSE CAN KILL. ALL
RIGHT NOW IS THE TIME
PROPOSITIONS THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NO ONE IN ONE
TWELVE IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION TO AND
AB. TEN TWENTY TWO. HERE WE DO
HAVE SOME IN QUEUE FOR THAT.
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE TWO
FIFTY SIX. TO FIFTY SIX ONE IS
OPEN. MISTER MEMBERS RYAN
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE THE-
AND STRONGER. TO THE BILL ON
POLICY GROUNDS. WHEN I GO TO
LINE TWO HUNDRED ONE TWO
HUNDRED ONE IS OPEN. CYBERLINK
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE
USURPATION LOS ANGELES DEPUTY
SHERIFFS HAVE ALSO BEEN ASKED
TO COMMUNICATE THE OPPOSITION
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO POLICE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION THANK YOU.
WHERE TO GO TO LINE. FIFTY
FOUR. HI THIS IS MATTHEW EASILY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. BLIND. TO THIRTY
EIGHT. MRS CLINTON WITH THE
LOCK OF JOSIAH YOUNG AND WE ARE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
BLACK CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THIS BILL I WOULD
NOTE THAT THE BILL MAY LET ME
RESULT IN UNKNOWN BUT
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT STATE
REIMBURSABLE COSTS. TO LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
DEVELOP POLICIES AND TRAINING-
WELL THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
MANDATE IS UNKNOWN. COULD
EASILY REACH INTO THE MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY WHEN
CONSIDERING THE NUMBER. OF
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
XIN'AN PIECE FIRST STANDARDS IN
TRAINING. DOESN'T CURRENT HAVE
ENOUGH FISCAL UPDATE MAYBE ONE
TIME COSTS IN THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND TO UPDATE AVAILABLE
GUIDELINES. AND TRAINING
MATERIALS. LASTLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION A DOES NOT HAVE
A SPECIFIC COST ESTIMATE AT
THIS TIME OF ANTICIPATE ONE
TIME COSTS IN THE RANGE OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND. THANK YOU SEEING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TEN
TWENTY TWO. WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON AB TWENTY
SIXTY ON DRINKING WATER. PIPES
AND FITTINGS AND LEAD CONTENT-
I SEE SOMEONE IN THIS ROOM WHO
WANTS TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. THE
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS JERRY
DOES MEN ON BEHALF OF PLUMBING
MANUFACTURERS INTERNATIONAL
SUPPORT THE BILL AS A KID WAS
DEVELOPED AND WENT THROUGH
CENTER PHARMACOLOGY AND HOPING
MOTHER BILLS ON SUSPENSE IT
WILL BE ABLE TO. ADDRESS THE
COST PRESSURES THAT ARE
IDENTIFIED IN THE ANALYSIS.
THANK YOU. SIGNAL ELSE IN THIS
ROOM WITH A ONE THERE'S NOBODY
IN ONE TWELVE. MODERATORS
HAVING ONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY SIXTY.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIR THERE IS NO WINNING QUEUE
TO SPEAK. ALL RIGHT. SEEING FOR
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSERS W. ONE
TWELVE OPPOSED ANYONE ON THE
PHONE NINE OPPOSED. AB TWENTY
SIXTY AND AGAIN. FOR TWENTY IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE MIN. ZERO
THERE IS NO WINNING QUEUE. ALL
RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. IF
YOU MISTER CHAIR DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL
ESTIMATES COST OF SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
FROM THE TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL ACCOUNT TO TEST FOR THE
STANDARDS IDENTIFIED IN THIS
BILL WE WOULD NOTE THAT THAT
ACCOUNT IS STRUCTURALLY
IMBALANCED WITH EXPENDITURES
EXCEEDING REVENUES BY SEVERAL
MILLION DOLLARS. AND ABSENT A
MAKE MAJOR FEE INCREASE
DIRECTION EXISTING RESOURCES.
FINE CAN SUPPORT THESE CALL.
AND THE GENERAL FOR HAS BEEN
REQUIRED TO BACK FILL THIS
FUNDING. THE WATER BOARD AS TO
MAYES THAT WHILE NOT REQUIRED
IN THE BILL THERE'S AN
EXPECTATION TO POST COMPLIANCE
REPORTS ON ITS WEBSITE. THE
DEVELOPMENT AND MAINTENANCE OF
THIS COULD RESULT IN COSTS IN
THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS. LASTLY WE NOTE THIS
BILL MAY RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
COST PRESSURES TO THE STATE I
JUST FOR REPLACEMENT OF END USE
DEVICES THAT DON'T NEED
SPECIFIED STANDARDS. ALL RIGHT
SINGLE HANDS GO UP WITH A OF.
AB TWENTY SIX WILL GO TO SAYS.
MOVING ON AB NINE NINE FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
ON HAZARDOUS WASTE. SHE IS
WAIVE PRESENTATION THERE'S NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY ONE TWELVE IN
SUPPORT. MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
AB. NINE NINE FIVE. IT WAS TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS.
ONE ZERO FOUR NINE NINE FIVE.
THERE IS NO WINNING QUEUE. ALL
RIGHT NOW IS THE TIME FOR
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM IS NOBODY IN ONE
TWELVE TWENTY ONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED AB. NINE NINE
FIVE. SPEAKING OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO.
RESEARCHERS AND WANTING TO. ALL
RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THIS BILL I WOULD
NOTE THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL
ESTIMATES COST OF NINE POINT
SEVEN FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN JUST CLEAR
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
TEN POINT NINE TEN POINT EIGHT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. I TO ESTABLISH AND
SUPPORT THE BOARD AND THE
FIASCO FORCE PROVIDED FOR THE
BILL. I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
AND OUT YEARS THAT FEES ARE
EXPECTED TO FULLY FUND THE
PROGRAMS. THAT WE KNOW THAT THE
BILL ITSELF DOESN'T PROVIDE.
FUNDING OR IF YOU MECHANISM. I
WOULD NOTE THAT THE DTS HE'S
PRIMARY FUND SOURCES THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL ACCOUNT
AND THE TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL CAN'T COUNT. ARE BOTH
STRUCTURALLY IMBALANCED. I WITH
EXPENDITURES EXCEEDING REVENUES
BY SEVERAL MILLION DOLLARS AND
CANNOT SUPPORT THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL. LAST
THE DEPARTMENT OF HAS MADE SOME
HUNDRED SAN NINE DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
ONE POINT. THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE LEGAL SERVICES
FOR ALL THINGS FUND. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB NINE NINE
FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPECTS MOVING
TO MISTER MAN SHINES- FILLED
HIS WAY PRESENTATION ON AB
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR ON HEALTH
CARE SERVICE PLANS- SIGN FOR
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY HERE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ONE TWELVE IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT OF AB. ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AGAIN WE ARE AT HOME ON A BILL
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR IF YOU ARE
QUEUED UP TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF. ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR. PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. WE DO HAVE
SOME PEOPLE IN Q. YOU KNOW TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE CALLING
IN FOR THE CORRECT BILL. ONE TO
SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS YVONNE
MARTIN NOT SHALL- ADDRESSING
THE CORRECT BILL BUT UNLESS THE
FINALS PERFECT SERVICES AS A
MENTOR TO INCLUDE. TURKEY I
HOPE I GO. I AM CALL UP WITH OF
TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN THANK YOU.
ABOUT AND WE'RE GONNA GO TO
LINE TWENTY FIVE IN THE HOPES
THAT THEY ARE CALLING ABOUT THE
RIGHT BILL JUST A MOMENT BY
TWENTY COLLECTED SO. THIS IS
TRUCK WHITE I WAS CALLING A THE
PRIOR BUILD NINE NINE FIVE FOR
SOME REASON DIDN'T TAKE UP WHAT
I. ZERO ONE SO I WOULD LIKE TO
ABOUT THE TO IT I'M A
REGISTERED PREPARE AND YOU. AND
I'M A PAST PRESIDENT OF THE CAL
REAR RESTORED. ASSOCIATE THAT
REPRESENTS. PROFESSIONALS IN
THE HOUSE OF THOSE WAYS
INDUSTRY CAL ARM. OPPOSES NINE
HER NINETY FIVE ON. THERE IS
AMENDED TO BE SOME NEAR VISIBLE
MEANS OF CALL THE- EIGHTEEN
MILLION FUND GAP. WITHOUT
CAUSING MORE WASTE BE EX. FROM
OUR- TWO OTHER JURORS. BUT
THEY'RE NOT. FEES OR IMPOSE THE
SAME MANAGED I AM YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH HE RESPECTFULLY OF AB
NINE NINETY FIVE HI. OKAY WE'RE
ON AB ALLOW TO FOUR MODEL. SO
WE'VE BEEN IN. SO WE'LL SEE IF
ANY OR OP. AB LET TWENTY MAKES
WE GIVE. A CHANCE SPEAK ON.
ELEVEN TO FOUR. AND AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE ARE ON
BILL. ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR. AND
AGAIN I APOLOGIZE MISTER CHAIR
THERE IS NO WINNING QUEUE AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT I THINK
WE'VE GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
BOTH SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION ON
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR- MATER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YOU HAVE
A FILE ON AB ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR. YES THANK YOU WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE OTHER
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE ESTIMATES COSTS TO
BE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND AND TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS BETWEEN TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN. AND.
300-980-0020 TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT. I WOULD KNOW THAT
THE BILL PROVIDES OF THE
DEPARTMENT- REGIONAL EXPENSES
TO BE REIMBURSED BY UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS BY THE
PILOT PARTICIPANTS. BUT THE
ACTUAL COST OF THE DEPARTMENT
MAY EXCEED THE REIMBURSEMENT
STATUTORY LIMIT. THANK YOU.
RIGHT SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE TO MISTER CALDERON IS TO
BILLS HIS WAY PRESENTATION.
FIRST ONE IS AB ELEVEN SIXTY
ONE ON RECREATIONAL WATER USE
WAY BASINS. TIME FOR SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY IN ONE TWELVE IS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE. IN
SUPPORT OF AB. ELEVEN SIXTY
ONE. PRESS ONE NINE ZERO AT
THIS TIME LADIES AND GENTLEMAN.
SURE THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT NOW FOR OPPOSITION
THERE'S NO IN THIS ROOM IS
NOBODY IN ONE TWELVE TWENTY ONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB.
ELEVEN SIXTY ONE. TESTIMONY
MISTER TERRY BELIEVE WE HAD
SOMEBODY. JUST A MOMENT.
THEY'VE GOT THERE LINE MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO WINNING QUEUE
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
LEVINSON'S THE WATER. THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ESTIMATES COST OF A HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY FROM THE GENERAL FUND
FROM TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AND THE DIVISION OF
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTHDEPARTMENT WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ARE ESTIMATES
MINISTRY OF COSTS WOULD BE
OBSERVABLE AS LONG AS THE
NUMBER OF WAYS BASINS IN THE
STATE IS LIMITED TO LESS THAN
THREE. OF FUNDING WE WOULD NOTE
THAT DOWN THERE THIS BILL MAY
CREATE A REIMBURSABLE STATE
MANDATE THANK YOU THANK YOU SEE
NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION ELEVEN SIXTY ONE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING TO AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY AND CORPORATE
SECURITIES LIMITED EXEMPTIONS.
STUDY TIME FOR SUPPORT THERE'S
NO ONE HERE IN ONE TWELVE
THERE'S NO ONE THERE TO ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE. IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY.
BUDGETARY BELIEVE WE MAY HAVE
ONE PERSON IN SUPPORT OF THAT
BILL JUST A MOMENT PLEASE.
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE TWO
SEVENTY NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE IS
OPEN. EMITIR APPEARS WE'VE LOST
THEM AGAIN AS WELL WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION. AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
THERE'S NOBODY HERE THERE'S
SOMEBODY IN ONE TWELVE IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB. TWENTY ONE FIFTY.
AND AGAIN IN OPPOSITION TWENTY
ONE FIFTY PLEASE PRESS. ONE
NINE ZERO. MISTER CHAIR THERE'S
NO WINNING QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE THERE'S A DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE HAVE A FILE. NO I
HAVE NO FILE ON THIS MISSION
ALL RIGHT WITHOUT OBJECTION
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
GOES TO SUSPENSE. AB ELEVEN
NINETY SIX MISTER GIPSON AND AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY FIVE MISTER
GIPSON HE'S WAY PRESENTATION ON
BOTH. A. B. ELEVEN NINETY SIX
NOW IS THE TIME FOR. YOUR
SUPPORT TESTIMONY THERE'S NO
ONE HERE THERE'S NO ONE IN ONE
TWELVE. IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN NINETY SIX PEACE
OFFICERS USE OF FORCE. MISTER
CHAIR WE DO HAVE BUT MORE
RESPONSES THIS TIME JUST A
MOMENT OUR FIRST CALLER JUST A
MOMENT. WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE
TWO THIRTY FIVE. POINT TWO
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINES OPEN.
YEAH THIS IS HENRY DAY MR CHIU
ON BEHALF OF RACIAL JOKES
COMMITTEE THING DIEGO IN. SUIT.
ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. KENYON MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF THE QUALITY CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. I WANT. TO SIXTY NINE.
THIS IS THAT SIMEONE GANT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
NATIONAL ACTION NETWORK AROUND.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
LARGEST. ONE TWO SEVENTY ONE.
HI THIS IS SAM NASH ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION SUPPORT. BY.
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN. HI THIS IS
VALERIE WITH BAD WOODSTOCK
COALITION POMPONIA AND RACIAL
JUSTICE COALITION OF SAN DIEGO
IN STRONG SUPPORT. BY TWO
SEVENTY TWO. HELLO MY NAME IS
ERIC MORE METS REPRESENTING
POLICY LINK IN THE ALLIANCE OF
BOYS MINUTE COLOR WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
NINE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
LINE. TO TWENTY NINE. HI MARIE
COOK CO SIGNED WITH STUCCO
MISSION IN THE JUST COLDEST AND
I'M FROM OR FOR A B. HELLO
NINETY. THANK YOU. FOR APPLE
DECLINED. TO NINE. GOOD MORNING
CHRISLEY CALIFORNIA NEW SO
SUPPORT. FIND. THIRTY EIGHT.
MORE CLINTON OF THE WITH THE
OFFICE OF JUST I YOUNG RAPPERS
THE COUNCIL BLACKED OF COMMERCE
AS WELL AS THE- CALIFORNIA NINE
GAS VEHICLE CALLED. INSTEAD.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE IN YOU.
RIGHT NOW IS THE TIME FOR A-
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM ON
ELEVEN NINETY TO NO ONE IN RE
ONE TWO IS THERE ANYONE I THE
PHONE LINE. OPPOSED A BILL.
NINETY SIX. TO GO TO A LINE
FIFTY SIX. LINE IS OPEN. HMM
RYAN SHERMAN THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. HERE WE HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL PERSON HE'S KILLING
UP JUST A MOMENT. BY. TWO
SEVENTY FOUR. WHAT CAN MORE
WITH YOU W. IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT COMPARTMENT A FINANCE.
THANK YOU WELL THE BILL DOESN'T
EXPLICITLY REQUIRE TRAINING AND
ONLY PROHIBITS AUTHORIZATION OF
CERTAIN RESTRAINTS AND HOLDS TO
THE EAST AND THE CALIFORNIA'S
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
RETRAIN CURRENT PEACE OFFICERS
AND SUBMIT ASSOCIATED CLAIMS.
AWFUL THAT THIS COULD BE FOUND
TO BE A REIMBURSABLE MANDATE
THE MAGNITUDE OF SUCH CLAIMS IS
UNKNOWN AND WILL DEPEND ON A
DETERMINATION BY THE
COMMISSION. THAT COULD BE
SIGNIFICANT. OTHER DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION ESTIMATES ONE
TIME COST OF FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND. TO MODIFY
EXISTING POLICIES. ADDITIONALLY
TO THE EXTENT THEY RETRAIN
EMPLOYEES OR ITS ONLINE
LEARNING MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
TRAINING PORTAL A ONE TIME
COSTS THAT MAY EXCEED FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND GENERAL FUND.
LASTLY THE COMMISSION ON PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING
A DOESN'T CURRENTLY HAVE AN
ESTIMATED FISCAL. BUDGET EXTENT
THEY HAVE TO UPDATE GUIDELINES
OUR TRAINING MATERIALS THAT MAY
BE ONE TIME BECAUSE IN THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND. BAR
SEEING NO HAN GO UP WITHOUT OF.
A. B. ELEVEN NINETY SIX GO TO
SAYS. HAVING TO AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY FIVE ON INVASION OF
PRIVACY NOW'S THE TIME FOR
SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE HERE AND
THERE STONE AND ONE TWELVE IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
AT SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY SIX
FIFTY FIVE. AND AGAIN FOR
SUPPORT OF TWENTY SIX FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE MIN ZERO.
I'M GONNA GO TO LINE TWO THIRTY
TWO. THE LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING BRANDON UP ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT LET'S GO
TO OPPOSITION SIR ANYONE
OPPOSED AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
FIVE THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM NO ONE IN ONE TWELVE FOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB.
TWENTY SIX FIFTY
FIVE. WE LOSE OUR MODERATOR.
PARDON ME MISTER CARE AND AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THERE IS NO WINNING
KILL ALL RIGHT BERMAN FINANCIAL
FILE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
RUNNING TRONG THE STATURE OF
THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICE
ESTIMATES COST OF LESS THAN TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO
UPDATE THEIR STATEWIDE MASTER
CARD TABLES AND PROCESS
RESTAURANTS. AND ALTHOUGH- THE
BILL DOES REQUIRE FIRST
RESPONDERS TO NOTIFY THEIR
EMPLOYEES ABOUT THE PROHIBITION
WE BELIEVE- IS UNLIKELY THAT
INDIVIDUAL AGENCIES WILL INCUR
A THREE. THOUSAND DOLLARS SINCE
THE BILL REQUIRES A ONE TIME
NOTIFICATION ON JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. ALL RIGHTS
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
FIVE. WITHOUT A SUSPENSE MOVING
ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES
HAS AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN SHE
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. AND
IT'S TIME FOR SUPPORT THIS IS
ON REGIONAL BUSINESS TRAINING
CENTERS. THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NO ONE IN ONE
TWELVE IS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN. PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE IN Q. AS
THE TIME FOR OPPOSITION THERE'S
NO ONE IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NO
ONE IN ONE TWELVE IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB. FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN. THERE IS NO WINNING YOU.
ALL RIGHTS BERMAN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE- WELL THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CURRENTLY PARTNER WITH THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL ON
JOB TRAINING INITIATIVES IT'S
UNCLEAR THAT THE CENTERS OF THE
CAPACITY TO SUPPORT THE
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED
WITH TEN NEW REGIONAL TRAINING
CENTERS. AS A RESULT THIS MAY
RESULT IN ANOTHER POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND COSTS TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE UNKNOWN BUT POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT NEW GENERAL FUND
COSTS FOR THE LABOR AGENCY AND
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IT IS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SINGLE HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN. WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING N TO MISTER
JONES SAWYER HE'S GOT A NUMBER
OF BILLS HE IS WAIVED
PRESENTATION ON ALL OF THEM. AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY FIVE DEALS WITH
CANNABIS AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS. NOW THE TIME FOR
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM IN SUPPORT THERE'S NO IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE IN SUPPORT. FOR
ANYONE IN. THE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN
TWENTY FIVE MODERATOR. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
GOING TO GO TO LINE NINETY ONE
IS OPEN. FISHERMEN MEMBERS IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN TWENTY
FIVE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTY TREASURERS AND TAX
COLLECTORS AND MISS ALL THE
OTHER. WE LOST. I WILL GO TO
THE NEXT. ONE IN PARTICULAR
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO ALL
RIGHT NOW IS THE TIME FOR
OPPOSITE. AND THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSE THE ONE IN
TWELVE OR ANYONE I THE PHONE
OPPOSED AB. FOR TO FIVE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO ZERO TWO THIS TIME
IF YOU LOOK TO SPEAK OFFICE. TO
TWENTY FIVE. BUT TO CHAIR
THERE'S NO WINNING QUEUE AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT BERMAN
FINANCE. THANK YOU THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ESTIMATES COST OF A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
FROM THE CANNABIS CONTROL FUND
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AN ON GOING. AND IF YOU TO
AGRICULTURE ESTIMATES COST OF
TWO HUNDRED THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE CANNABIS
CONTROL FUNDING TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING OF
CANNABIS CONTROL. INDICATES THE
COST IN HOME AND THE STILL ARE
LARGELY UNKNOWN BECAUSE OF THE
UNIDENTIFIED VOLUME OF REQUESTS
TO BE YOUR ONLY RECEIVED. AND
COSTS WOULD BE DEPENDENT ON
THAT VOLUME. I WOULD KNOW THAT
WE DO ESTIMATE OF THE COST TO
UPDATE ITS ONLINE APPLICATIONS
TO COMPLY WITH THE BILL. OF
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
ONE TIME. RIGHT SHE NOT SCHOOL
WITH THAT OF. AB FIFTEEN TWENTY
FIVE GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING AB
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE ON FALSE
REPORTS AND HARASSMENT. NO TIME
FOR SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NO ONE IN ONE
TWELVE. IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO I
BELIEVE WE HAVE SOMEONE ON THE
LINE FROM ONE TO FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS KELP
OCCURS PLAN TO CALIFORNIA'S
NURSES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NOW S
THE TIME PROPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN ONE TWELVE TWENTY ONE
ON THE PHONE LNE WHO WAS
OPPOSED AB. SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. SURE THERE'S NO
WINNING KILL ALL RIGHT. BERMAN
FINANCE THANK YOU WE DON'T HAVE
A POSITION ON THIS MEASURE BUT
WE KNOW THAT THE BILL COULD
IMPOSE NEW COSTS AND WORKLOAD
ON COUNTIES WHICH CREATES
ADDITIONAL FISCAL PRESSURE ON
THE LOCAL CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM ADDITIONALLY DEPARTMENT
OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
INDICATE THE BILL MAY RESULT IN
MINOR CIRCLE COSTS RELATED TO
THE CASE RUSSELL RIGHTS ACT
PROVISION OF THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SEVENTY
SEVENTY FIVE. WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON THE AB TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY ONE. ON THE
CALIFORNIA SCIENCE CENTER. IT'S
TIME FOR SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM IS SERVE NO ONE
TEN ONE TWELVE IS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE. IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY ONE. IF
YOU ARE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY ONE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
YOU HAVE SOMEONE IN THE
QUEUE IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT
WHAT WE GIVE THEM THEY'RE
IMPLYING NUMBERS THANK YOU. THE
SCHOOL NEXT TO SCIENCE CENTER.
CALLING OFFICER THEIR- OFFICE
FOR. A WHOLE STATE. AGAIN IF
YOU ARE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY ONE
YOU CAN PRESS ONE AND THEN.
ZERO PER TWO HUNDRED AND.
SEVENTY SIX NINE TWO SEVEN SIX.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN OR
SHAME LEVINE ON BEHALF OF CS
ONLY A- STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THIS BILL THIS BILL SIMPLY
CODIFYING THE MO YOU BETWEEN
BARGAINING UNIT SEVEN IN THE
MINISTRATION- WITHOUT FEAR
ABOUT THANK YOU. OKAY OKAY IF
YOU ARE A TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE TEN ZERO.
THIS IS THE- YEAH. BOB. IF YOU
HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
CONSIDER ALL RIGHT NOW IS THE
TIME OPPOSITE ON TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY ONE THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOMTHERE'S NOBODY IN ONE
TWELVE. IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY NINETY ONE THE- IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE AB TWO EIGHT
NINE ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE. AB. TWO EIGHT NINE ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK. YEAH YEAH.
I WILL NEVER GET BACK RIGHT
EXACTLY. NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT
BERMAN FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THIS BILL WILL
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL COSTS FOR
THE SCIENCE CENTER IN
EXPOSITION PARK AS RESULT OF
THE INCREASED COSTS FOR
SALARIES AND RETIREMENT WE
ESTIMATE ONGOING COST OF THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ANNALYNNE
ANNUALLY OTHER ALSO BE
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME TRAINING
AND CERTIFICATION COSTS.
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN RESOURCES
ANTICIPATES ADMINISTRATIVE
WORKLOAD TO THE HUMAN RESOURCES
THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
AND THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT SYSTEM FOR
THE EMPLOYEES IMPACTED BY THIS
BILL WOULD REALIZE THE
RETIREMENT CLASSIFICATION
CHANGE FINALLY THERE IS A
POTENTIAL FOR ADDITIONAL FISCAL
IMPACT DUE TO THE
CLASSIFICATION CHANGE WHICH
WOULD NEED TO BE NEGOTIATED.
THROUGH THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS. ALL RIGHT
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY ONE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
OR MOVING TO MISTER BLOOMS TO
BILLS HE'S WAY PRESENTATION ON
BOTH AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO ONE
SOLID WASTE. THIS IS THE TIME
FOR SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE. IN SUPPORT
OF AB. SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO. IF
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY N SUPPORT
OF AB ONE SIX SEVEN TWO. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
SIX SEVEN TWO. YOU WILL PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE ADELINE
ONE EIGHT TWO ONE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THIS IS KRISTIN JOHNSON WITH
COACHELLA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
CALLING IN SUPPORT. AND IF YOU-WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO
ONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. STRICTLY COME TOP
POSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM NOBODY IN ONE TWELVE IS OR
ANYONE ONLINE OPPOSED AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO. IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION
HE WILL PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO
WELL. THERE IS NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE BERMAN
FINANCE. THANK YOU AT THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
ESTIMATES COSTS OF TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND.
242-122-2420 FIVE HOWEVER WE
WOULD NOTE THAT DISCUSSED
NEEDING MINOR AN OBSERVABLE.
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ESTIMATES COST OF TWO
HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN DOLLARS
TWO HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE UNDER
COMPETITION LAW FUNDED TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO MANAGE AND
ADMINISTER THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
PROGRAM- WE WOULD KNOW HOWEVER
THAT A PORTION OF THE
PROVISIONS ARE PERMISSIVE BY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THAT
ANY REQUEST RESOURCES WOULD BE
EVALUATED DURING THE BUDGET
PROCESS. ALL RIGHTS SIGNAL
HANDS GO UP AB SEVENTEEN ACTION
MAY BE SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO.
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE LIVING ON
AB. SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX LICENSE
I DON'T RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES
AND RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES- NOW IS THE TIME FOR
SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM. THERE'S NO ONE IN ONE
TWELVE IS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX. IF YOU ARE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
SEVEN SIX SIX. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT THE END IS ZERO. ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. I
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
TWO LINE TWO EIGHT TWO YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. THANKS FOR VISITING
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. IF YOU
ARE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. EVERYONE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
ALL RIGHT NOW IS THE TIME FOR
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSE OR SOMEONE IN
ROOM- ONE TWELVE IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. TO AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
SIX. IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB. ONE
SEVEN SIX SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. EVERYONE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHT
BERMAN FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT RESULTS
IN INCREASED GENERAL FUND COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACT WE ANTICIPATE
ACOSTA SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER. ALL RIGHT SING O
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX COSTA
SUSPENSE. MOVING TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS. A. B. EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE SHE HAS WAY
PRESENTATION. ON THIS HOMELESS
FAILED. THIS IS THE TIME FOR
SUPPORTERS NO ONE HERE IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE IN ONE
TWELVE. TWENTY ONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB. EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE. IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
EACH FOR FIVE. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE EACH FOR
FIVE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN.
ZERO WE HAVE MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE NINE TWO
EIGHT ONE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. THE
SPANISH OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU. IF YOU WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE
QUEUING UP PLEASE CONTINUE ALL
RIGHT NOW CENTER PROPOSITION
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSES GOING AND ONE TWELVE
OPPOSED TO ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE. IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE. A.
B. EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO. AGAIN
TO OPPOSE AB ONE EIGHT FOUR
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN.
ZERO I HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE BERMAN FINANCE.
THANK YOU AND THIS BILL IS
ESTIMATED TO RESULT IN GENERAL
FUND COSTS IN THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS AFTER THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE NEW
SECRETARY AND ADMINISTRATIVE
RESOURCES. WE KNOW THAT WE ARE
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL MISSY
MINEAR STRETCHES EXPLORING WAYS
TO ACHIEVE EFFICIENCIES ARE TO
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS BY
ENSURING BETTER COORDINATION
BETWEEN STATE DEPARTMENTS AND
MORE EFFECTIVE COLLABORATION.
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HOWEVER
WE DO NOT A CONCERN THAT THIS
BILL MAY BE PREMATURE GIVEN THE
DISCUSSIONS ARE STILL UNDERWAY
TO DETERMINE THE BEST
ORGANIZATIONAL STRUCTURE. TO
ACHIEVE SUCH EFFICIENCIES. ALL
RIGHTS IN NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE. WITH A SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON MISTER ROGERS TO BILLS
HE'S WAY PRESENTATION- FIRST
ONE IS A IS AB NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT NOW IS THE TIME FOR
SUPPORT. THERE'S NO ONE HERE
THERE'S ONLY ONE TWELVE. SO
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT. TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE NINE SIX EIGHT YOU WILL
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEY PAD AGAIN TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF AB ONE
NINE SIX EIGHT. YOU WILL PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. EVERYONE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL
RIGHT IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM NOBODY IN
ONE TWELVE TWENTY ONE THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED AB NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT. TRIBAL LAND USE
TECHNOLOGY WHICH. IF YOU WISH
TO OPPOSE AB ONE NINE SIX EIGHT
YOUR PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
EXCUSE ME IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE
AB ONE NINE SIX EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO
ONE SHOWING UP ON THE PHONE
PLEASE CONTINUE EICHEL AND
PARDON ME WE DO WE DO HAVE
SOMEONE KEEPING UP ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM THEIR
LINE NUMBER. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB ONE NINE
SIX EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO.
IS THERE A PERSON
THERE. YOU I. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY
SIX NINE TWO NINE SIX YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS VANESSA
TWENTY ASK I'M A RESIDENT OF
SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND I SUPPORT
AB IN NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT.
OKAY AND I BELIEVE WERE
CHECKING TO SEE IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB ONE NINE SIX EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE
FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE.
ALL RIGHT BERMAN FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THE COMMISSION
WASN'T ABLE TO PROVIDE US WITH
THE FISCAL ESTIMATE- COMPLETION
OF THIS ANALYSIS OF THAT WE
KNOW THAT THE WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED- IS LIKELY TO BE
MINOR AN OBSERVABLE- WE WOULD
NOTE HOWEVER THAT THE BILL
CREATES UNKNOWN COST PRESSURES
FOR OWNERS OR OPERATORS. OF
PUBLIC SCHOOLS STATE OR LOCAL
PARKS LIBRARIES MUSEUMS OR
STATE OR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. TO
ADOPT PLANNING KNOWLEDGE AND
PROCESSES. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHTS SINGLE HANDS UP WITHOUT
A- AB NINETY SIXTY. FOUR GOT A
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON AB TWENTY ONE
TWELVE. ON SUICIDE PREVENTION.
NOW IS THE TIME FOR SUPPORT
THERE'S NO ONE HERE THERE'S NO
ONE IN ONE TWELVES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE TWELVE. IF YOU WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE TWELVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO ONE ONE
TWO. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. YEP MY NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE SIX SEVEN.
KELLY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
QUALITY CALIFORNIA THE COURT.
MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SIX POINT TWO FIVE SIX YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. WIND CHILL RIVERSIDE
SHARES. OR. OKAY THANK YOU AND-
ANYONE ELSE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB WENTY ONE
TWELVE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE FOR SUPPORT PLEASE GO
AHEAD ALL RIGHTS TIME
PROPOSITION TWENTY ONE IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSED. NINE THIRTY ONE
AND ONE TWELVE OPPOSED NONE SO
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO AB. TWENTY ONE
TWELVE. IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE
AB TWENTY ONE TWELVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY
ONE TWELVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN. ZERO THERE IS NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT BERMAN
FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE- BECAUSE IT CREATES
ONGOING GENERAL FUND OR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FUND COST
PRESSURE ADDITION WOULD NOTE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AS WELL AS THE
COMMISSION CONTINUE TO DO
EXISTING SUICIDE PREVENTION
EFFORTS I WOULD NOTE THAT THIS
BILL CREATES A COST PRESSURE TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
OF ONE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE AND ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER TO ESTABLISH AND
pCOSTS WOULD BE SUPPORTED EITHER
BY THE GENERAL FUND OR THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND.
AND IT DOESN'T IT DOESN'T SOON-
THAT THE DEPARTMENT WOULD
ESTABLISH THE OFFICE AFTER THE
TWO MILLION DOLLARS OF MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FUNDS. INCLUDED
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT.
THE COMMISSION TO PERFORM
ACTIVITIES IS NO LONGER
AVAILABLE FOR EXPENDITURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SEE NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWENTY
ONE TWELVE WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN HAS.
ONE TWO THREE. IF
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO AGAIN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE NINE SEVEN
NINE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN.
ZERO I HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
FOR SUPPORT PLEASE CONTINUE
THERE WAS A TIME PROPOSITIONS.
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSES
ANYONE IN ONE TWELVE NO FOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE. IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE A. B. NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE ALL
RIGHT BERMAN FINANCE. THANK YOU
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
AS IT WOULD RESULT IN GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURE IN THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS TO TENS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS A
GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY. TO
REQUIRE COUNTY TO APPROVE
PAYMENT TO A- TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROVIDER FOR UP TO
FOURTEEN DAYS IN A CALENDAR
MONTH. I WOULD ADDITION I KNOW
THAT SEVERAL PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL WERE CONSIDERED IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS BUT WERE
ULTIMATELY NOT INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT.
FINALLY WE NOTE THAT THIS BILL.
APPEARS TO LIMIT COUNTY
FLEXIBILITY. ALL RIGHT AND- A-
SEE NINE WILL OBJECTION AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON AB
THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR ON FIRE
PREVENTION. IS THERE SUPPORT
NOT IN THIS ROOM NONE IN ONE
TWELVE IS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
SEVENTY FOUR. TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY SEVENTY
FOUR YOU MAYPRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. YEP MY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE NUMBER.
TWO ZERO FIVE. THE MORNING
GOING TO MANAGE ANY OTHER
KNOWLEDGE AND QUICK THINKING.
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND IN NINETY ONE LINE TWO NINE
ONE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HELLO
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE CHAVEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS AND THE
COURT. YEAH ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
ARE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE YOU MAY
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT NOW IS THE
TIME PROPOSITIONS- TO AB THIRTY
SEVENTY FOUR THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN ONE
TWELVE IS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB. THIRTY
SEVENTY FOUR. IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE A BI THIRTY EIGHT
SEVENTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN. ZERO ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE A. B. THIRTY
SEVENTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN. ZERO I HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION YOU MAY
CONTINUE THANK YOU BYE-
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THANK YOU A
CAL FIRE WASN'T ABLE TO PROVIDE
AN UPDATED ESTIMATE FOR THIS
VERSION OF THE BILL- BUT WE DID
IDENTIFY COSTS A FIFTY ONE
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS.
ELEVEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
WHICH WAS A GENERAL FUND FORTY
POINT ONE MILLION WHICH WAS A
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND.
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND FORTY POINT SIX MILLION
ON GOING TO PERFORM DEFENSIBLE
SPACE INSPECTIONS AS WELL AS
PUBLIC EDUCATION AND OUTREACH.
TO ACHIEVE COMPLIANCE WITH THE
AMBER RESISTANCE NOT
REQUIREMENT CREMATE CREATED BY
THIS BILL. WE WOULD NOTE THAT
THE FISCAL IMPACT WILL LIKELY
BE LESS. THAN THE COST
INITIALLY IDENTIFIED A GIVEN
THE LEVEL OF RESOURCES IN PLACE
FOR EXISTING. A DEFENSIBLE
SPACE RELATED ACTIVITIES. AND
ALSO NOTE. IS THE COULD RESULT
IN A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE. AS THE BILL REQUIRES
LOCAL AGENCIES TO MAKE
REASONABLE EFFORTS TO NOTIFY
RESIDENTS ARE IN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS OF THE NEW
DEFENSIBLE SPACE REQUIREMENTS.
OPERATION POSING PENALTIES FOR
NON COMPLIANCE. LASTLY WE DID
WANT TO KNOW THAT IT'S POSSIBLE
THE BILL COULD RESULT IN THE
MITIGATION OF FUTURE DISASTER
COSTS. HOWEVER THE EXTENT OR
SCALE OF ANY. POTENTIAL FUTURE
SAVINGS IS AND NOW. THANK YOU
SEE NO HANDS COPER OBJECTION.
THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR OVER THE
SUSPENSE A. B. THIRTY ONE SIXTY
FOUR ALSO ON FIRE PREVENTION.
NOW IS THE TIME FOR SUPPORT
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM NO
ONE IN ONE TWELVE IS ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE. IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY FOUR. IF
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY FOUR.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE TWO NINE ONE. THE TALIBAN
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA DIVISION
WELL TO THIS REPORT. THANK YOU
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
TWO ZERO FIVE. GOOD MORNING
RECALLING THAT BEGIN WITH
SENDING ATTACKS AND LET YOU CAN
SUPPORT TEAM. IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
ONE SIXTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. NO ONE ELSE IN
THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT YOU MAY
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT NOW IS THE
TIME FOR OPPOSITION THERE'S NO
ONE HERE THERE'S NO ONE IN ONE
TWELVE IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSE. TWO AB.
THIRTY ONE SIXTY FOUR. IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE AB THIRTY ONE
SIXTY FOUR THE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT
THANK YOU. NINE TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE TWO NINE SEVEN. YES HELLO
MY NAME IS THAT ARE GONE.
UNLESS PROFESSIONAL SERVICES
ARE AMENDED TO INCLUDE
TRANSLATORS AND INTERPRETERS I
OPPOSE. AND AGAIN WE ARE ON E.
B. THIRTY ONE SIXTY FOUR IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE AB THIRTY ONE
SIXTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETY SEVEN- THE LINE IS OPEN
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME
IS LOOSENED BETTER RUN. ELLIS
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES ARE
AMENDED TO INCLUDE TRANSLATORS
AND INTERPRETERS I OPPOSE. IF
ANYONE ELSE WISHES TO GET INTO
THE QUEUE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTY ONE SIXTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WILL YOU
BE MORE PRODUCTIVE. THIS. WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. TO
OPPOSE AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE CONTINUE R. I.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE IT'S THIRTY
SEVENTY FOUR I'M SORRY NO
THIRTY ONE. SIXTY FOUR. YES
THANK YOU I CAL FIRE ESTIMATES
THE BILL WILL COST TWO POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWO POINT SIX MILLION
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AND ONE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
ONGOING DEVELOPMENT TEAM THE
RISK MODEL. AS WELL AS JUST LET
THE OTHER REQUIREMENTS OF THE
BILL. TWENTY DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE ESTIMATES COST OF
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
AND THIRTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
ON GOING FROM THE INSURANCE
FUND. TO ASSIST IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE RISK
MODELING TO PARTICIPATE AS A
MEMBER OF THE ADVISORY
WORKGROUP. LASTLY MIDDLE COULD
RESULT IN THE MITIGATION OF
FUTURE DISASTER COSTS OUR THE
EXTENT OR SCALE OF ANY
POTENTIAL SAVINGS IS AND NOW.
ALL RIGHT WITHOUT OBJECTION A.
B. THIRTY ONE SIXTY FOUR WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON AB
THIRTY TWO SEVENTY NINE ON
SEQUEL. THERE'S NO ONE IN THE
ROOM IN SUPPORT NOW'S THE TIME
FOR SUPPORTERS KNOWN IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE DURING ONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY TWO SEVENTY NINE ON C.
CLASS. IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO
SEVENTY NINE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN IF ZERO. LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
THE LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THE
NASA CHARTERED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AND SUPPORT. NINE TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY EIGHT NINE
TWO NINE EIGHT YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING AFTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE NINE ALEJO
PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA YIMBY AND
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY TWO SEVENTY NINE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. FOUR OUT
OF SUPPORT YOU MAY CONTINUE ALL
RIGHT NOW WHAT OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY ONE TWELVE IS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE. IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTY TWO
SEVENTY NINE. IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB THIRTY TWO SEVENTY
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB THIRTY TWO SEVENTY
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME YOU MAY
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THANK YOU THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
INDICATES COST OF THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE
ENERGY RESOURCES PROGRAM
ACCOUNT OR VIA. ONGOING
GENTLEMAN THE BILL WOULD KNOW
BETTER BUT IS IN A STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT AND ANY INCREASE IN
EXPENDITURES WILL EXACERBATE
THE STRAIN ON THE ACCOUNT ALIKE
THEY CELEBRATE ANY NEED FOR A
FEE INCREASE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION INDICATES COST OF
A HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND A
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE OIL GAS AND
GEOTHERMAL ADMINISTRATIVE FUND
ONGOING IMPLEMENT THIS BILL.
AMASSING WE NOTICED THE ONLY
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL COSTS ARE
AND COST PRESSURES FOR BOTH
STATE AND LOCAL PUBLIC AGENCIES
ABOUT ELECTED AND I
PETITIONER'S REQUEST. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHTS SIGNAL. HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB THIRTY TWO
SEVENTY NINE. WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. DURING TO MISTER
BIGELOW AB TWENTY FORTY ON
PROPERTY TAX COUNTY MADERA.
TIME FOR EASE WAY PRESENTATION
TIME FOR SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY
IN THE ROOM NOBODY IN ONE
TWELVE IS ANYONE ON THE HONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY
FORTY. IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FORTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO.
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT
POINT TWO EIGHT EIGHT YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS CALL YOUR BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN MADERA
COUNTY YOUR ANALYSIS LESSONS
ACTUALLY SPOT ON ON THE FISCAL
SAYS THE COMMITTEE MUST BALANCE
THE ISSUE OF FAIRNESS RELATED
TO THE STATE DELAYS IN AUDITING
THE COUNTING WHICH COMPOUNDED
THE MAGNITUDE OF THE ERROR. WAS
CURRENT GENERAL FUND DEFICIT IN
FISCAL STRAIN BECAUSE LIKE OF
THE NINETEEN. RESPECTFULLY TO
BALANCE THESE THINGS WHICH IS
HELP THE RELIEF TO MADERA
COUNTY CAN BE MERITED- EVEN IN
THESE DIFFICULT TIMES AND. IN
THE BILL TO GET ASSISTANCE
THANK YOU. IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FORTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. YOU HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE YOU MAY CONTINUE
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM NOBODY AND ONE TWELVE
IS OR ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
OPPOSED AB TWENTY FORTY. IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
FORTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AGAIN IT YOU FOR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FORTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I
KNOW ONE IS IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THANK YOU WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THIS BILL
BUT WOULD NOT THAT BE
ALLOCATING FOUR POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
EDUCATIONAL REVENUE
AUGMENTATION FOUNDER EUROPE
WILL REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
PROPERTY TAX RECEIPT BY THE
COUNTY STREET AT TWELVE SCHOOLS
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES ON A
DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR BASIS. THIS
WILL DRIVE THE NEED TO REDIRECT
PROP NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND
TO THE COUNTY SKATER TWELVE
SCHOOLS UNDER THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA. BECAUSE WE ARE
JUST ONE OF PROPOSITIONS. JUST
WANNA PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT-
IT'S EXPECTED TO BE OPERATIVE
FOR THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE YOU
LARGELY. TO DECLINING
ENROLLMENT. THE OVERALL AMOUNT
OF PROP NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND PROVIDED TO THE SCHOOLS
ARE STATEWIDE WILL REMAIN THE
SAME. I WOULD NOTE THAT IF
CIRCUMSTANCES CHANGE IN TEST
TWO OR THREE BECOME OPERATIVE
THAT SOME OR ALL OF THE FOUR
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS WILL
BECOME A NEW PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND COST. ALL
RIGHT SIGNAL HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB TWENTY
FORTY WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LIMóN AB TWENTY SIXTY ONE. SHE
HAS A WAY OF PRESENTATION AND
POWERS THE TIME FOR SUPPORT.
THERE IS NO ONE IN THIS ROOM NO
ONE IN ONE TWELVE IS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
AB. TWENTY SIXTY ONE. THE
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORTOF AB
TWENTY SIXTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. THIS IS ON
FIREARMS. AGAIN TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIXTY ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO
ONE IS IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY SIXTY ONE ON
FIREARMS THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM NO ONE THE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE IS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE INE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SIXTY ONE. IF YOU WISH
TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY SIXTY ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB
TWENTY SIXTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. THERE IS NO ONE
IN Q. FOUR OPPOSITION YOU MAY
CONTINUE RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL AS
IT COULD RESULT IN GENERAL FUND
COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT AND TO
THE EXTENT OF THE DEALERS
RECORD OF SALE SPECIAL ACCOUNT
IS UNABLE TO ABSORB ADDITIONAL
COST. SULTAN ADDITIONAL GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURES TO BACK
FILL THAT FUND. WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES- COST OF A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. HUNDRED SEVENTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
AND THIRTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER.
REGULATIONS AND TO CONDUCT AT
LEAST TEN COMPLIANCE
INSPECTIONS AT GUN SHOWS
ANNUALLY. I MEAN TO THE EXTENT
THE DEPARTMENT TAKES A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATOR. INVESTIGATORY
APPROACH RATHER THAN
COMPLIANCE. THESE COSTS WOULD
INCREASE SUBSTANTIALLY. ALL
RIGHT SIGNAL HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWENTY
SIXTY ONE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE IN AB TWENTY ONE OH ONE.
WHICH IS A COMMITTEE BILL ON
PUBLIC EMPLOYEE RETIREMENTS.
NASA TIME FOR SUPPORT THERE'S
NO ONE HERE AND ONE TWELVE IT'S
EMPTY. TWENTY ONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
ONE OH ONE. IF YOU ARE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE OH ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON THE PHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO ONE ZERO ONE.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
THE PHONE KEYPAD WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE TO FIGHT
FOR. YOU CAN TRICKLE IN
MARTINEZ WAIT CALIFORNIA STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AGAIN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWO ONE ZERO ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
YOU HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
FOR SUPPORT YOU MAY CONTINUE
ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY ONE OH ONE THERE'S NO
ONE HERE THERE'S NO ONE IN ONE
TWELVE IS THERE ANYONE. ON THE
PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION. TO
TWENTY ONE OH ONE. IF YOU WISH
TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY ONE OH ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ON
THE PHONE KEYPAD. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY
ONE OH ONE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO ONE IN A POSITION IN THE
QUEUE YOU MAY CONTINUE. ALL
RIGHT BERMAN FINANCED TWENTY
ONE OH ONE. THANK YOU ACCORDING
TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM THE
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
RETIREMENT SYSTEMS AND THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SYSTEM. I ANY
ADMINISTRATIVE OR PROGRAMMATIC.
COSTS IMPOSED BY THE BILL WOULD
BE MINOR IN OBSERVABLE. CASTERS
DOES ESTIMATE THAT THE BILL'S
PROPOSAL TO CLARIFY THE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT LAW.
REQUIRES THE PAYMENT OF MEMBER
AND EMPLOYEE CONTRIBUTIONS IN
THE AMOUNTS OF ROUGHLY ONE
HUNDRED NINETEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS
RESPECTIVELY. AS THERE'S NO
MECHANISM TO RETROACTIVELY
COLLECT IN THE STATE OF THIS
CHANGE WILL NOT FISCALLY IMPACT
THE STATE. I SEE NO HANDS GO
UP. AB TWENTY ONE OH ONE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING. TO MR
RODRIGUEZ ON. HIS THREE BILLS
AB TWENTY ONE OVER TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN ON HIGHER EDUCATION-
THERE'S NO ONE HERE AND
SUPPORTERS KNOWN AS ONE TWELVE
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF. TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN. IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
ONE FOURTEEN. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SEVEN LINE TWO EIGHT
SEVEN YOU MAY GO AHEAD. I'M
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
MICHELLE CAPTURE THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
WE ARE THE SPONSORS OF THE
SPELL AND TO SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE. I'M SORRY I
WAS DISTRACTED BERMAN. OUT YEAH
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN YOU MAY CONTINUE. ALL
RIGHT- LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION
SIR ANYONE OPPOSED NO ONE HERE
IN A ONE ON ONE TWELVE. ANYBODY
IN ON THE PHONE LINE. IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY SIX LINE TWO FOUR SIX
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. TIELINE TWO
FORTY SIX WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN
FOR YOU I JUST MOMENT. THE
MORNING AND EDUCATE THEM. CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YOU MAY CONTINUE
THANK YOU. RIGHT MICHAEL BUT
ARE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA YOU
SEE IS OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
THE TWO ONE ONE FOUR AND EXPECT
BETWEEN ONE POINT EIGHT AND
FOUR HALF MILLION DOLLARS IN
ANNUAL COSTS FOR ARBITRATION
APPRECIATE THE CONTINUED AND
SUSTAINED ENGAGEMENT ON THE
BILL BY THE AUTHORED SPONSOR.
THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE
HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY CONTINUE.
ALL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE-
TO THE POTENTIAL FOR ADDITIONAL
GENERAL FUND COSTS AS
PREVIOUSLY STATED BY THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM UC
ANTICIPATE COST BETWEEN ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION AND FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY WHICH
INCLUDES ONE TIME COSTS IN THE
HUNDREDS OF LOW HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO MAKE
CHANGES TO EXISTING POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES. ARE BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY IN
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF THE LAW. I
JUST PAID ANY IMPACT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN WOKOU TO SUSPENSE AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN ON PP-
NOW IS THE TIME FOR SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY HERE. TWENTY
MILLION ONE TWELVE IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
THERE'S NO ONE IN ONE TWELVE
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF. TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN. HE WAS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. NINE THREE HUNDRED
AND TWO THREE ZERO TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RESEARCHER KIRSTEN
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION THE PROBLEM
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. IF
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I
HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE FOR
SUPPORT YOU MAY CONTINUE ALL
RIGHT NOW IS THE TIME
PROPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM NOBODY AND ONE TWELVE
IS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE.
OPPOSED. TO TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN. IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN YOU
MADE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN. ZERO I HAVE NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION YOU
MAY CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT BERMAN
FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON
THIS BILL AT THE TIME BUT
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
ESTIMATES ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
COSTS IN THE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO PROCURE A SIX MONTH
STOCKPILE OF PP FOR ITS FIVE
STATE HOSPITALS ADDITIONALLY
THE PART OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ESTIMATES ENFORCEMENT
OF THIS BILL WOULD BE MINOR AN
OBSERVABLE WITHIN THEIR
EXISTING RESOURCES. ALL RIGHT
SINGLE HANDS CLUB WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON TO AB THIRTY TWO
TWENTY FOUR ON A LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT AND WORKFORCE
ASSESSMENTS. NOW IS THE TIME
FOR SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN ONE
TWELVE AS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
TWO TWENTY FOUR. IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
TWO TWO FOUR. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY NINE
NINE TWO NINE NINE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS NICOLE
WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF SAN
BERNADINO COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED THAT'S
LINE THREE ZERO ZERO YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. THERE CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE JACK
ANDERSON CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CO SPONSORS OF AB THREE TWO
TWO FOUR THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA TO HELP UP THERE'S
INSTITUTIONAL CALIFORNIA AND S.
YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT
THAT IS LINE TWO EIGHT EIGHT
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS POPULAR BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SOLANO
NOBLE COUNTY SHOULD SUPPORT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE TWO TWO FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO IF NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT
YOU MAY CONTINUE ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM NO ONE IN ONE TWELVE
WAS OR ANYONE. ON THE PHONE
LINE IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU WISH
TO OPPOSE A. B. THIRTY TWO
TWENTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AGAIN TO OPPOSE A.
B. THIRTY TWO TWENTY FOUR YOU
MAY PRESS. ONE TEN ZERO. IF NO
ONE IN THE QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION
PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT
FORMER FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE'RE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT RESULTS
IN SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND
IMPACTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
APARTMENT ABOUT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH ESTIMATES COST OF TWO
POINT SEVEN FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND OVER TWO
AND A HALF FISCAL YEARS. FOR
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL.
OUR ICING NO HANDS GO UP.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB THIRTY
TWO. TWENTY FOUR WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING TO MISTER
KALRA HE HAS A WAY PRESENTATION
ON HIS THREE BILLS BUT HE DOES
HAVE ONE TO PASS WE WILL GO TO
TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN FIRST
HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLANS- I'M
FOR SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM- NO ONE IN ONE TWELVE
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY ONE
EIGHTEEN. TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB. TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
ONE ONE EIGHT. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN. ZERO NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE FOR SUPPORT YOU MAY
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT NOW IS THE
TIME FOR OPPOSITION THERE'S NO
ONE IN HERE THERE'S NO ONE IN
ONE TWELVE IS ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTEEN. IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AGAIN TO OPPOSE AB TWO ONE ONE
EIGHT. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN.
ZERO I HAVE NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION IN THE QUEUE YOU MAY
CONTINUE BERMAN FINANCE. THANK
YOU THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE ESTIMATES COST OF
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN. TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ONE HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. ONE
HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE- AND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER.
NOTE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
INSURANCE ALSO ESTIMATES COSTS
OF THIRTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND FIFTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE FROM THE INSURANCE FUND.
I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL BUT NO
CONCERNS. BECAUSE THE RESULTS
IN COST FOR MANAGED CARE FUND
IN THE INSURANCE FUNDS WHICH
WERE NOT INCLUDED IN OUR
CURRENT FISCAL PLAN. ALL RIGHT
A SEE NO OBJECTION WITHOUT THE
SIGNAL HAS GONE WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTEEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
TWO ON CRIMINAL PROCEDURE.
NOW'S THE TIME FOR SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM TO
BE IN ONE TWELVE ANYBODY ONLINE.
FOR TWENTY FIVE FORTY TWO IF
YOU WAY. IF YOU ARE TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE FOR AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TEST OF IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO FIVE FOUR TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO
YOU HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
FOR SUPPORT YOU MAY CONTINUE
RIGHT NOW IT'S TIME FOR
OPPOSITION- THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM TO BRING IN ONE
TWELVE IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES PHOTOS. AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY TWO. IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO I HAVE NO
ONE IN THE QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION
YOU MAY CONTINUE BERMAN FINANCE.
THANK YOU THE DIGITAL COUNCIL
ESTIMATES THE BILL COULD HAVE A
FISCAL IMPACT BETWEEN NINE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS AND
FORTY POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
AS A RESULT OF INCREASED TRIAL
COURT WORKLOAD AS THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL CREATE
BY THE RETROACTIVE AND
PROSPECTIVE WORKLOAD. THE
VICTIM COMPENSATION BOARD
INDICATES THE BILL WILL HAVE A
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE
RESTITUTION FUND BECAUSE IF.
CONDITIONS ARE VACATED A
RESTITUTION NOT BE RECEIVED FOR
THOSE CASES. AND WHILE THERE'S
NOT A SPECIFIC FISCAL IMPACT.
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL. THE
BOARD HAS INDICATED IT COULD
RESULT IN A REVENUE REDUCTION
IN THE LOW MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE BILL
COULD HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ON STATE LOCAL CRIMINAL JUSTICE
RELATED COSTS HOWEVER THE
MAGNITUDE IS UNKNOWN AND WENT
DEPEND ON NUMEROUS FACTORS.
LASTLY WOULD KNOW THAT THE BILL
COULD INCREASE STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE REQUIRING
THE PROSECUTION TO DISCLOSE ALL
EVIDENCE TO THE DEFENSE
RELIGION RELATIVE TO ONE OF
THESE CASES. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
TWO. WILL GO TO SUSPENSE WILL
MOVE ON TO AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WITH SENATOR
LEYVA. PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA. SO
SENATOR PLEASE TELL US ABOUT.
EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND DO IT
RIGHT FROM THERE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
WITH YOU HERE TODAY. AB TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT WOULD
PROHIBIT HOSPITAL EMPLOYERS
FROM REQUIRING EMPLOYEES AND
JOB APPLICANTS FOR DIRECT
PATIENT CARE PROVIDERS TO PAY
OR REIMBURSE EMPLOYERS FOR
EMPLOYER MANDATED. EMPLOYER
PROVIDED TRAINING OR PROGRAMS
AND CREATE A RETALIATION
PROTECTION IF THEY REFUSE TO
ENTER INTO A CONTRACT OR AN
AGREEMENT FOR THE EMPLOYER
MANDATED TRAINING. THIS BILL IS
ESTIMATED TO HAVE MINIMAL COSTS
FOR ENFORCEMENT BY THE DIVISION
OF LABOR AND STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT. PROVIDING
TESTIMONY TODAY WILL BE TAYLOR
JACKSON FROM THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT WE DO HAVE A
PRIMARY WITNESS ONLINE I HOPE.
YES JACKSON YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS HERE JACKSON TO THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
WE ARE THE BOTTOM THIRD OF AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT AT
SENATOR LEYVA SAID THE BILL
INSURANCE FOR WORKERS
TECHNICALLY BECOME EMPLOYED.
THEY ARE NOT TRAPPED INTO
PAYING FOR COSTS THE COURT THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE ALREADY
DETERMINED SHOULD BE BORNE BY
THE EMPLOYER UNITED THEME PARKS
AND OUR EMPLOYER SKIRTING
CURRENT LAW BY IMPOSING THESE
COP ON JOB APPLICANTS THROUGH
AN ETHICAL CONTRACTS- WE ARE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE I.
R. AND STAKEHOLDERS ON
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS THAT WE
SHOULD BE REACHING RESOLUTION
SOON WITH THE RELATIVELY MINOR
OFTEN MIND YOU AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
VOTE ON AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT. ALL RIGHTS. LET'S GO TO
THE PHONE LINE FOR ANY FURTHER
ME TO USE- PLEASE JUST STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR POSITION AND
YOUR ORGANIZATION. IF YOU WISH
TO GET INTO THE PHONE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO GET INTO THE PHONE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO THEY DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE- QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME YOU MAY CONTINUE. AND
FOR THE RECORD THERE WAS NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM WHO WAS WILLING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. AND WILL START WITH
THE OPPOSITION AND THERE'S NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM OPPOSING AND
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE OPPOSING SO WE'LL GO TO
THE PHONE LINE FOR ANYBODY WHO
WANTS TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT. IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. DO NOT HAVE ANYONE IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME FOR
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHTS BERMAN
FINANCE. THANK YOU THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ESTIMATES COSTS OF
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE FIRST
YEAR AND ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING
INTO LABOR ENFORCEMENT AND
COMPLIANCE FUNDS TO PROCESS ANY
WAGE CLAIMS RESULTING FROM THE
BILL. ALL RIGHTS MS LEVERAGE
LIKE TO CLOSE. BACKPASS FOR AN
AYE VOTE. OUR THIRTY WILL MOVE
THE BILL WE HAVE A MOTION AND
WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS. AND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. YES PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
PRESSURES ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
FIVE EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BATES NO BRADFORD. WITH
THIS FLUID MISSION SUPPORT
MOVEMENT TO A YES. BRADFORD BY
HILL JONES JONES NARROW LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE WIECKOWSKI HI
ASKEY I LEAVE THAT ON CALL FOR
MR HILLS. AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO
MISTER KALRA IS- LAST BILL SB
THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN ON AN
UNEMPLOYMENT RE HIRING AND
RETENTION- STATE OF EMERGENCY
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE QUESTION
THANK YOU FOR USING. THERE'S NO
ONE IN ONE TWELVE IN SUPPORT IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE TWO ONE SIX. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
TWO SIXTEEN. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. MY NUMBER'S THREE
HUNDRED AND NINE NINE THREE
ZERO NINE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. WE
THOUGHT OUR HOME FROM WORKING
PARTNERSHIPS USA AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB. THIRTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
NINE THREE HUNDRED AND ELEVEN
LINE THREE ONE ONE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. KATIE WATER SAMPLE THE
CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION AND TRANSPORT. AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE
IN SUPPORT YOU MAY CONTINUE.
ALL RIGHT NOW IS THE TIME FOR
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB. THIRTY
TWO SIXTEEN. IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THIS IS. THEN AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO OPPOSE AB THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY HAVE NO ONE
IN THE YOU FOR OPPOSITION MAY
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. YES WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THIS BILL THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ESTIMATES COSTS OF
ONE POINT THREE FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS INITIALLY AND ONE POINT
TWO SIX MILLION DOLLARS ON
GOING FROM THE LABOR
ENFORCEMENT AND COMPLIANCE FUND
A TO ENFORCE THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL. ALL RIGHTS SINGLE
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AB THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO THE
VETERANS AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
TWENTY ONE NINETY TWO- THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT
ANYBODY AND I'LL BEFORE WE DO
THAT- LET'S LIFT THE CALL ON AB.
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT. ALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO FIVE EIGHT EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. HELLO HI THERE ARE. AT
BILLS OUT. ALL RIGHT WE CAN
CLOSE THAT ROLE LET'S MOVE ON
TO FACT BECAUSE MR JONES WAS
HERE EVERYBODY WAS HERE- AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY TWO. VETERANS
AFFAIRS THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM AND SUPPORT NOBODY IN ONE
TWELVE IN SUPPORT. IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY ONE
NINETY TWO. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY NINE ONE
NINETY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWO ONE NINE TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. IF
WHAT HAVE YOU. I NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED AND FOUR LINE THREE
ZERO FOUR YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS KERIS MY
TWITTER NAY BE ON BEHALF OF THE
MILITARY SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. IF YOU
ARE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWENTY ONE NINETY TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE FOR
SUPPORT YOU MAY CONTINUE. ALL
RIGHTS OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANYONE OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY TWO NO ONE'S IN THIS
ROOM KNOW ENGINE ONE TWELVE
THIRTY ONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY
ONE NINETY TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN. ZERO WE'RE SORRY YOUR
CONFERENCE WILL END IN FIVE
MINUTES. I HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION ON AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY TWO YOU MAY
CONTINUE. FORMER FINANCE. THANK
YU THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES NO
ADDITIONAL COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS BILL. ALL RIGHTS
SINGLE HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
TWO WITH A SUSPENSE MOVING THE
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY SEVEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN- SHE HAS
WAY PRESENTATION- THERE'S NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT NOW
STRIVE FOR SUPPORT NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM NO ONE IN ONE TWELVES
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE. IN
SUPPORT OF TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
SEVEN. YOUR TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AGAIN IF YOU ARE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO
ONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION
THERE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED THERE'S. TO TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN SINGLE IN HERE NO
ONE IN ONE TWELVE- IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE- IS
SUPPOSED. TO TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
SEVEN. IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB.
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. SEVEN NO
ONE IN THE QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION
YOU MAY CONTINUE. BY DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. TELL RECYCLE
ESTIMATES COST OF A HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND ONE HUNDRED TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING FROM
THE INTEGRATED WASTE MANAGEMENT
ACCOUNT WOULD NOTE THAT THE
ACCOUNT HAS A STRUCTURAL
IMBALANCE YOU CANNOT SUPPORT
THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
BILL AND THEREFORE THIS BILL
CREATES A GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURE. OKAY WITHOUT
OBJECTION I SEE NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN. WILL GO ON THE
SUSPENSE MOVING TO. AB. TWENTY
TWO NINETY THREE MISTER MAYES
HIS WAY PRESENTATION PRODUCT
OBSTRUCTION PULMONARY DISEASE-
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE IN SUPPORT AS ANYONE ON
THE PHONE IN SUPPORT. IF YOU
ARE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO TWO NINE THREE. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
TWO NINE THREE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. THANK YOU WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED
AND FIVE ONE THREE ZERO FIVE
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN JOHN
VALENCIA REPRESENTING GLAXO
SMITH KLINE IN SUPPORT OF
TWENTY TWO NINETY THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE Y.
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
NINE. NINE THREE ONE SIX ONE
MOMENT PLEASE THANKS NINE THREE
ONE SIX FOUR LAURIE YOUR
CONFERENCE WILL END IN ONE
MINUTE. YES WE HAD LINE THREE
ONE IN AND IT BREAKS AS SOON AS
WE FINISH THIS BILL. EMPIRE
READY WILL. ALL RIGHTY GOOD
NIGHT YEAH. THANK YOU THANK YOU
WILL CLOSER ALIGN THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT I THINK WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO SUSPEND IN THE MIDDLE
OF THIS BECAUSE I WANT TO GET
SHUT OFF SO WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
FIFTEEN MINUTE RECESS WILL BE
BACK IN FIFTEEN MINUTES AND WE
WILL PICK UP. WITH AB. TTWENTY TWO NINETY THREE
WE ARE BACKIN COMMITTEE. SO MEMBERS COULD
COME ON BACK WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP PROCEEDING. WE LEFT OFF
WITH MR MAYES. AB TWENTY TWO
AND WE WILL START WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT IN FAVOR OF. TWENTY TWO
NINETY THREE THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM. THERE'S NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. AND THERE ARE
PEOPLE ON THE LINE- I HAVE TO
READ MY NEW THINGS SO. LET ME
DO THIS SO. FOR PEOPLE WATCHING
A STREAMING US THERE'S A NEW
CALL IN. ACCESS CODE SO FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL ALSO BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN. AND
I'M GOING TO ANNOUNCE IT NOW.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBERS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. 1-116-364-8442.
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
AND THE ACCESS CODE THE NEW
ACCESS CODE IS SIX NINE EIGHT.
FOUR FIVE NINE ONE SO. SIX NINE
EIGHT FOUR FIVE NINE ONE AND
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS GO
TO. THE SENATE OR THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND OBVIOUSLY. WHEN WE
MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY THE MODERATOR TO
DIE ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR THE
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
THIS CAN TAKE WHILE. PLEASE BE
PATIENT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE
KEY OR THE QUEUE. FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME WE WILL BE
ON MUTED AND THEN YOU'LL BE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY. TO
AVOID FEEDBACK. PLEASE MOVE
YOUR DEVICE THAT YOU'RE
WATCHING OR HEARING US ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY. THAT WE
WILL BE ABLE TO HEAR FROM YOU
ON AND CONVERT. SO AGAIN NEW
ACCESS CODE SIX NINE EIGHT
FOUR. FIVE NINE. 798-459-8236
NINE EIGHT. FOUR FIVE NINE ONE.
IS THE ACCESS CODE. WITH THAT
WE WILL GO TO MISTER MAYES
PUBLIC COMMENT IN FAVOR OF
TWENTY TWO NINETY THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM. NOBODY IN
ONE TWELVE AND MODERATORS OR
ANYONE. ON THE PHONE LINE IN
FAVOR OF TWENTY TWO NINETY
THREE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY TWO NINETY THREE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AGAIN TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWO TWO NINE
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
THIS REPEAT THE INSTRUCTION IF
YOU ARE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO TWO NINE THREE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THIS
IS. YOUR. NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
FOR A SUPPORT PLEASE CONTINUE
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION
TO ANYBODY OPPOSED TO TWO
TWENTY TWO NINETY THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN ONE TWELVE MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ONLINE WHO IS
SUPPOSED TO AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY THREE. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO TWO NINE
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB TWO TWO NINE THREE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I
HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION YOU MAY CONTINUE.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
FINANCE. THANK YOU WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE
IT CREATES NEW COSTS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THAT WEREN'T INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT AT THE
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES COSTS OF
SEVEN HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS INCLUDING FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
SUBCONTRACT THE OUT REACH AND
HEALTH EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS
AND TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AFTER
RESOURCES TO MANAGE THE
CONTRACT IN MONITOR- THE
PROVIDER AWARENESS CAMPAIGN.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY THREE WILL
GO ON SUSPENSE MOVING TO MR
QUIRK AB TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD. HE IS WAY PRESENTATION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM. TO
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE THIRTY ONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY
TWO NINETY SIX. AND IF YOU WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ONCE AGAIN
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWO TWO NINE SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME WE'RE
SUPPORT YOU MAY CONTINUE ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION TO
ANYBODY OPPOSED AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY SIX. NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
SOMEBODY IN ONE TWELVE IS
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
SIX. IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB.
TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN TO
OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
SIX. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE PHONE KEY. I HAVE
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION YOU MAY CONTINUE
FINANCE. THANK YOU WE ESTIMATE
THAT THE BILL WILL REQUIRE
UNKNOWN BUT POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT ANNUAL FUNDING TO
THE WATERBOARDING OF THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. WHICH
CREATES COST PRESSURES ON
VARIOUS FUNDS- BASED ON SOURCES
IDENTIFIED IT IN THE BILL
INCLUDING THE GENERAL FUND.
ADDITIONALLY THE WATER BOARD
ESTIMATES TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THE SAFE DRINKING
WATER ACCOUNT IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND ONGOING. WE
KNOW THAT DEPENDING ON THE
NUMBER OF LOCAL PHARMACY
AGENCIES THAT OPT INTO THE
PROGRAM. THE WATER BOARD MAY
HAVE TO REQUEST AN INCREASE
APPROPRIATION AUTHORITY. AND
POSITIONS TO PROVIDE EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM OVERSIGHT. UNLESS THEY
WOULD WANT TO KNOW THE STATUTE
PLACES A CAP ON THE SAFE
DRINKING WATER ACT EXPENDITURES
AND LIMITS ANNUAL INCREASES TO
FIVE PERCENT. ALTHOUGH THE
EXACT NUMBER OF LOCAL PRIMACY
AGENCIES THAT WOULD CHOOSE TO
PARTICIPATE IS UNKNOWN. THE
BILL MAY BE RESULT IN THE NEED
FOR INCREASES BEYOND THE CAP.
WHICH. WOULD CONFLICT WITH
EXISTING STATUTE. R. I. C. NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX BY
MISTER CORK WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING DAY BE THIRTY
TWO TWENTY- COMMITTEE BILL FROM
THE ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND
TOXIC MATERIALS- COMMITTEE.
THERE'S NO PRESENTATION IS
THERE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM KNOW
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE IS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE. IN SUPPORT OF THE
COMMITTEE BILL AB THIRTY TWO
TWENTY. WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE TWO TWO
ZERO. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AGAIN TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO
TWENTY. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE PHONE KEYPAD. I
HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE FOR
SUPPORT YOU MAY CONTINUE. ALL
RIGHT TO THEIR OPPOSITION SING
NO ONE IN THIS ROOM KNOWN AND
ONE TWELVE WAS THERE ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB
THIRTY TWO TWENTY. IF YOU WISH
TO OPPOSE AB THIRTY TWO TWENTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB THIRTY
TWO TWENTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. YOU HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION YOU MAY
CONTINUE OUR RIGHTS DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
ESTIMATES NO ADDITIONAL COST
FOR THIS BILL TO EXTEND ITS
EXISTING PROGRAM. ARETINO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION THIRTY
TWO TWENTY ONE OH TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON TO MR CHIU. AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY. HERE'S A WAY
PRESENTATION AND THERE'S NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM FOR SUPPORTERS OR
pIS THE TIME FOR SUPPORT. NO
WHEN THERE'S OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN. IF
YOU ARE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
SEVEN. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEY PAD
AGAIN FOR TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT. OF AB TWO THREE SEVEN
SEVEN. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN.
ZERO NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME TO SUPPORT YOU MAY
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT NOW IS THE
TIME PROPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
ONE TWELVE IS OR ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINES IN OPPOSITION. TO
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON THE PHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN Q. OPPOSE AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN. YOU
WILL PRESS ONE THEN ZERO WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER FOURTEEN LINE
ONE FOUR YOU MAY GO AHEAD. YES
THIS IS BOB NEAL REPRESENTING
SIX BEDS AND CAN ASSOCIATION OF
SMALL ASSISTED LIVING AND ADULT
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES. WERE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL ON THE
GROUNDS THAT THE- A RIGHT OF
FIRST REFUSAL PROVISION WILL IS
UNFAIR AND WILL DISCOURAGE
INVESTMENT AND MORE A. R. S.
WHICH WE NEED. THANK YOU. IF
YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB. TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. IF NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION YOU MAY CONTINUE.
ALL RIGHT TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. IF YOU MISTER CHAIR WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE- AS
THE PROVISIONS WERE CONSIDERED
DURING THE BUDGET PROCESS BUT
ULTIMATELY NOT INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT- THIS
BILL WOULD CREATE GENERAL FUND
COST PRESSURES TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
ABOUT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. TO ESTABLISH A
CONTRACT FOR TEMPORARY MANAGER.
ADDITIONALLY. WOULD KNOW THAT.
THE BILL REQUIRES. TELL TO
COMPLY WITH THE BILL'S REQUIRES
DREAMERS DSS FOR THEIR COSTS
HOWEVER WE'RE NOT CLEAR ON THE
TIMING OF THOSE REIMBURSEMENTS
THANK YOU. ALL WRITING NO HANDS
GO UP. WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING TO MS
BURKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS WE
PRESENTATION ON HER TWO BILLS
FIRST ONE IS AB TWENTY FOUR OH
FIVE RIGHT TO SAFETY SENATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- TIME FOR
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN ONE
TWELVE THIRTY ONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FOUR. OH FIVE. IF YOU ARE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN IF
YOU ARE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. I HAVE NO ONE
IN THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT PLEASE
CONTINUE. BOB I'M SORRY.
BILLBOARD SO FAR OPPOSITION
THANK YOU MISTER WACHOWSKI.
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM AS
OPPOSED NOBODY IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE OPPOSED TO ANYONE ONLINE
OPPOSED. IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE
AB TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY FOUR
OR FIVE. YOU MAY PRESS. ZERO
ALRP BONE PICTURE BRENDAN. I
HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE ALL
RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU YES- WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THE MEASURE BECAUSE IT MAY
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND COSTS ARE POTENTIALLY IN
THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY AND MAY CREATE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE. THANK YOU
SEE NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWENTY FOUR OH
FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING TO AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
EIGHT OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND
HEALTH HAZARDS. NOW IS THE TIME
FOR SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN
HERE THERE'S NOBODY IN ONE
TWELVE. GENTLEMAN GENTLEMAN WHY
CASKEY SH. ALL RIGHT YOU CAN
TAKE IT OUTSIDE. ALL RIGHT
TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT IS THERE
ANYONE ONLINE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT. IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SIX FIFTY. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. ONCE AGAIN IN
SUPPORT YOU WILL PRESS AB TWO
R. PARDON ME FOR IN SUPPORT OF
AB. TWO SIX FIVE EIGHT YOU WILL
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEY PAD. YEP NO ONE
QUEUING UP IN SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT TIME PROPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM NOBODY IN
ONE TWELVE SURE ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT. IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE AB. TWENTY SIX
FIFTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. ONCE AGAIN IT FOR
OPPOSITION OF AB. TWENTY SIX
FIFTY EIGHT YOU WILL PRESS ONE
THEN. ZERO WE HAVE NO ONE
QUEUING UP IN OPPOSITION YOU
MAY CONTINUE ALL RIGHT PART IN
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS ESTIMATES
COST OF ONE HUNDRED NINETY
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE
LABOR ENFORCEMENT AND
COMPLIANCE FUNDING TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER. PROCESS
HEALTH AND SAFETY CLAIMS
RESULTING FROM THE STILL. CHINO
HANDS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT BECAUSE
THE SUSPENSE. MOVING TO MISTER
STONES AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE HE'S WAY PRESENTATION.
TIME FOR SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY
HERE THERE'S NOT ONE IN ONE
TWELVE GERMANY ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE. IF YOU WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND IF YOU ARE TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE
QUEUING UP FOR SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WELL GOOD
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSE OR SOMEBODY IN
ONE TWELVE OPPOSE IS THERE
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. TO TWENTY FOUR TO
TWENTY FIVE. IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB.
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I NO ONE
QUEUING UP IN OPPOSITION YOU
MAY CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT. BERMAN
OF FINANCE BUT- YOU DON'T HAVE
A BILL THAT WOULD NOTE THAT IT
MAY CREATE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE ON LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO SEAL
AND TO FACILITATE THE SEALING
OF JUVENILE RECORDS AS REQUIRED
BY THE BILL. AS WELL AS PROVIDE
NOTICE TO MINORS THE WHETHER
THE RECORDS HAVE OR HAVEN'T
BEEN SEALED AND IF NOT TO BUY
THEM WITH AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PURCHASE ADDITION
RECONSIDERATION. BEFORE TWENTY
FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
TO. OUR QUE HAN. AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY THREE. ON COUNTY JAILS
AND RECIDIVISM THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM NO ONE IN ONE
TWELFTH. SIR ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE. IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY THREE. IF YOU WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY THREE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY FOUR IGHTY THREE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO I HAVE
NO ONE TO QUEUING UP IN SUPPORT
YOU MAY CONTINUE ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION NOW
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSE IS THERE'S NO ONE IN ONE
TWELVE OPPOSED. TO ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY THREE. IF
YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY THREE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN. ZERO AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN. ZERO I HAVE NO ONE
QUEUING UP IN OPPOSITION YOU
MAY CONTINUE ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YES
WHERE OPPOSE THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE RESULTS IN JEFF GENERAL
FUND. IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT AND ME A CREATIVE
STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE
REQUIRING THE SHERIFF AND EACH
TIME TO COMPILE AND SUBMIT
SPECIFIED DATA TO THE BOARD OF
STATE AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS.
THE BOARD ESTIMATES INITIAL ONE
TIME COST OF THE PROSELYTISING
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND. AND OF
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
ON GOING. ALL RIGHTS SIGNAL
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY THREE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING TO
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX BY MR
GABRIEL. CON HOMELESSNESS.
THERE IS NO ONE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT NOW IT'S TIME FOR
SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE IN ONE
TWELVE IS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY SIX. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO
ONE QUEUING UP IN SUPPORT YOU
MAY CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT NOW IS
THE TIME FOR OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSE SAYS
NOBODY IN ONE TWELVE OPPOSES
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB. TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
SIX. IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB.
SEVEN FORTY SIX. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN IF ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEY PAD. AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE AB. TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN IF ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE
SHOWING UP ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY CONTINUE. IS
THERE A FILE. S. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT IMPOSES
GENERAL FUND COSTS ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
THAT WEREN'T INCLUDED IN TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACT AS WELL AS
OTHERS THAT BILL MAY CREATE A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE WITH
UNKNOWN BUT POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT COSTS. THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
ESTIMATES GENERAL FUND COST OF
FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE FIRST
YEAR AND A PERSONALLY FOUR
HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY THERE AFTER
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL MAY
RESULT IN UNKNOWN BUT
SIGNIFICANT COST TO MAKE
NECESSARY CHANGES TO THE STATE
WHAT AUTUMN. AUTOMATED WELFARE
SYSTEM. ALL RIGHT SINGLE HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE. MOVIE TO MISTER
O'DONNELL AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
FIVE. HE IS WAY PRESENTATION
THIS IS ON PUBLIC WORKS
PREVAILING WAGE THERE'S NOBODY
HERE IN SUPPORT. NOBODY IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE AND SUPPORTERS OR
ANYONE ONLINE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT OF. AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY FIVE. IF YOU ARE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN FOR
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. IT'LL
BE JUST A MOMENT WHILE WE
PROVIDE THE CALLER WITH THE
LINE NUMBER.
BLINDED CAN YOU ME
AT. YOU MEET YOU ARE IN THE
QUEUE NOW YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE ONE ZERO.
THANK YOU OPERATOR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TO
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL. OR THE SPONSORS BABY
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE VERY
BRIEFLY- REQUIRING CHARTER
SCHOOLS THAT RECEIVE PUBLIC
SUBSIDIES IN THE FORM OF CONDO
BOND FINANCING- WILL NOT ONLY
ATTRACT THE MOST COMPETENT
SKILLED TECHNICAL WORKFORCE.
BUT WILL ALSO SERVE AS A
STIMULUS DURING THE TIME WHEN
SCARCE TAXPAYER DOLLARS YOU
COULD BE SPENT WISELY ON
PROJECTS WE BELIEVE THEY SHOULD
BE SPENT PROVIDING PREVAILING
WAGES WHICH WHICH GOING TO
MIDDLE CLASS LIVELIHOODS FOR
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS- WE- OR- A
GREAT TIME. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO GET INTO THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME REGARDING AB TWO SEVEN SIX
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN.
ZERO I BELIEVE WE'RE STILL-
RIGHT NOW QUEUING UP FOR
OPPOSITION IS THAT CORRECT.
SUPPORT THANK YOU OPPOSITION
FOR AB TWO SEVEN FOUR SIX FOUR
NINE SO BEFORE ONE ZERO SUPPORT
FOR AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE.
I DO APOLOGIZE FOR SUPPORT OF
AB TWO SEVEN SIX FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. SEVEN NO ONE SHOWING UP
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SIX
FIVE YOU MAY CONTINUE RIGHT
WE'RE OPPOSITION OF TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE THERE'S NOBODY
IN THE ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
ONE TWELVE IS OR ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE. OPPOSED. TO TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE. IF YOU WISH
TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE THE
E. B. TWO SEVEN SIX FIVE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I HAVE
BY NO ONE QUEUING UP IN
OPPOSITION OF THE E. B. TWO
SEVEN SIX FIVE YOU MAY CONTINUE
ALL RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE. AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ESTIMATES THE
INCREASED COST OF ONE HUNDRED
NINETY EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN THE FIRST YEAR AND ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN EACH SUBSEQUENT YEAR
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PROVISIONS
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU SEE NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE GOES
TO SUSPENSE. AB TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY MISTER LOWE WAS WAY
PRESENTATION IT'S ON. SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA RAPID
TRANSIT. AND IT WILL TAKE A
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY HERE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ONE TWELVE IS
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER SEVENTEEN LINE AT
ONE SEVEN YOU MAY GO AHEAD. JIM
WHITE ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA RAPID
TRANSIT DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AGAIN IF YOU ARE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO. OR.
YEAH I DO NOT HAVE ANYONE IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME FOR A
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY YOU MAY
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE
ON TO OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY
AND- ONE TWELVE. WHEN HAVE TO
SEPARATE YOU GUYS EVEN FARTHER.
IS THERE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINE IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY. IF YOU WISH
TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
THE TELEPHONE KEY PAD. AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY
EIGHT FIFTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. NO ONE QUEUING UP IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY YOU MAY CONTINUE. ALL
RIGHTS I'M IN THE FINANCE.
ANOTHER COMPLAINANT RELATIONS
BOARD ESTIMATES ONE TIME COST
OF FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
PROMULGATE REGULATIONS IN UP TO
SEVENTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY TO
FACILITATE THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL WOULD ADDITIONALLY
NOTE THAT LOCAL AGENCIES- BY
REQUIRING LOCAL AGENCIES
REPRESENT THEMSELVES TO THE
BOARD A MAN POSES STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE. ALL RIGHT
SEE NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION TWENTY FIFTY WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE FOR MORE TO GO.
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY SIX BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. WILL TAKE
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY HERE
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY SIX. AS AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEY PAD. BEGAN TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO EIGHT SEVEN
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER NINETEEN
LINE ONE NINE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THAT
COMMITTEE THIS IS BEST BY NUNEZ
ON BEHALF OF SOCIAL CHANGE AND
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY SIX. THANK
YOU. AGAIN IF YOU ARE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY SIX. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. IF NO
ONE ELSE IN QUEUE FOR SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY SIX
YOU MAY CONTINUE WE'RE GOING
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY HERE
THERE'S NO MILLION ONE TWELVE
IS OR ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY SIX. IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON THE TELEPHONE KEY PAD. AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB.
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY SIX YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I HAVE
NO NGUYEN QUEUING UP IN
OPPOSITION OF THE E. B. TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY SIX YOU MAY
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT TO FROM THE
FINANCE. THANK YOU THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION ESTIMATES
IMPLEMENTATION COSTS OF ONE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND. ADDITIONALLY THAT
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD ESTIMATES NO
FISCAL IMPACT- RELATED TO THIS
BILL AS ALL FUNDING ASSOCIATED
WITH THE POPULATION WORKFORCE
TRAINING GRANT PROGRAM HAS
ALREADY BEEN DISTRIBUTED. IN
THE GROUP IS SUBSEQUENTLY
CLOSED OUT AS OF MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY HOWEVER I SHOULD
ADDITIONAL GRANT FUNDING BE
ALLOCATED FOR DISBURSEMENT
THERE WILL BE AN ANTICIPATED
FISCAL PRESSURE TO ADMINISTER
THE PROGRAM. OUR RIGHT SEEING
NO HANDS UP AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING TO MR OBERNOLTE. AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY HIS WAY
PRESENTATION THIS IS ON
HAZARDOUS WASTE. WILL TAKE
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY HERE
THERE'S NO MILLION ONE TWELVE
IS THERE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
NINE TWENTY. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
NINE TWENTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD AGAIN THAT IS TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWO NINE TWO
ZERO. BY NUMBER TWENTY NINE TWO
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTMAS
OUR BEHALF OF CLEAN HARBORS
ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO NINE
TWO ZERO THANK YOU. IF YOU WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. YOU HAVE
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY YOU
MAY CONTINUE ALL RIGHT WE'LL
TAKE OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THERE ANYBODY IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE NO ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO
TWENTY NINE TWENTY. GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY
NINE TWENTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEY
PAD. AGAIN TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY
NINE TWENTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. YOU HAVE NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY
NINE TWENTY YOU MAY CONTINUE
ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY HERE THERE'S NOBODY IN
ONE TWELVE IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
TWENTY NINE TWENTY. DOUBLE
CHECK ONE MORE TIME IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE PHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN
THAT IS IN OPPOSITION AB.
TWENTY NINE TWENTY YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO
ONE QUEUING UP IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
EXISTENCE IS CONTROLLED AND
DISSIPATES A DECREASES REVENUE
OF BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED AND
700-003-0020 THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY BEGINNING IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE DUE TO CONSOLIDATING THE
MANIFESTS. MANIFESTS FEE IS
DEPOSITED INTO THE HOUSE RISK
CONTROL HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL
ACCOUNT WHICH IS BEEN
EXPERIENCING STRUCTURAL
DEFICITS BY SEVERAL MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. WE WOULD NOTE
THAT THIS BILL INCREASED
PRESSURE ON THE GENERAL FUND TO
BACK FILL THESE REVENUE LOSSES.
THERE MAY RESULT YOUR MANIFEST
PROCESS BY BY THE DEPARTMENT
WHICH COULD RESULT IN COST
SAVINGS THAT COULD POTENTIALLY
OFFSET IN WHOLE OR IN PART. LOS
ALL RIGHT WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE WILL MOVE ON AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY TWO BY MISS WEBER
WHO WAS AWAY PRESENTATION ON
EMPLOYMENT PRACTICES AND LEAVE
TIME THERE'S TAKING SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY HERE THERE'S
NOBODY IN ONE TWELVES OR
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF TWENTY NINE NINETY
TWO. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
THE TELEPHONE KEY PAD. AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO
AND I HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE-
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
NINE NINE TWO ALL RIGHT- LET'S
TAKE OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
HERE THERE'S NOBODY ONE TWELVE
IS THERE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINE. OPPOSED TWO AB. TWENTY
NINE NINETY TWO. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE
AB. TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN
IF YU WISH TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN. ZERO THERE IS NO ONE
QUEUING UP IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO YOU MAY
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT APARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS ESTIMATES
THE BILL WOULD LIKELY. RESULT
IN A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF LABOR VIOLATION
CLAIMS WOULD YOU TO KATE
RESULTING IN A NEED FOR AN
ADDITIONAL THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS- LABOR
ENFORCEMENT AND COMPLIANCE FUND
FOR THE FIRST YEAR. AND THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONGOING. ALL RIGHT
SINGLE HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION TWENTY NINE NINETY
TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING
ON TO OUR FINAL BILL SB THIRTY
ONE THIRTY FOUR. BY RAMOS- AND-
PRESENTATION HAS BEEN RAISED
ITS ON REFUGEE SOCIAL SERVICES.
WILL TAKE A SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THE COMPANY
ONE TWELVES OR ANYBODY ON THE
LINE. IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY A.
B. THIRTY ONE THIRTY FOUR. AND
IF YOU ARE TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF THE E. B. THIRTY ONE
THIRTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF AB. THIRTY ONE
THIRTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO. AB THIRTY
ONE THIRTY FOUR ALL RIGHT WELL
GOOD APPOSITION THIS ANYBODY
OPPOSED NOBODY HERE NOBODY IN
ONE TWELVE ANYBODY ONLINE IN
OPPOSITION. TO THIRTY ONE
THIRTY FOUR. GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE A. B. THIRTY ONE
THIRTY FOUR AND YOUR ON THE
PHONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB
THIRTY ONE THIRTY FOUR. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN IF. ZERO I HAVE
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION ON E. B. THIRTY ONE
THIRTY FOUR YOU MAY CONTINUE.
ALL RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
JOLIET YOUR LAST MOMENT. IN THE
SUN CARE THANK YOU. OF THAT WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES HELLO MILLIONS OFDOLLARS ANNUALLY TO TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE THAT IS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE CURRENT FISCAL
PLAN THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE'LL
SEE A THURSDAY. ALL RIGHTS
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP. WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY
FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPENSE- THAT
IS THE LAST BILL WE HAVE
NOTHING ON FALL THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING HERE WE GOT A COUPLE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. THAT CONCLUDES
OUR HEARING FOR THE DAY I'D
LIKE TO THANK EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. IF YOU ARE NOT ABLE
TO GET YOUR TESTIMONY IN TODAY
FOR ANY REASON PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING. TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. THERE ARE THOSE TWO
GO HAND. THANK THANK YOU FOR
LIKE TWELVE YEAR OLDS IF YOU'RE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR
ANY REASON PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS.
THANK YOU AND WE ALSO
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR THEIR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION AS WE HAD A LITTLE
BIT OF A TECHNICAL SNAFU WHICH
WE NAVIGATED AND WE'VE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA THANK YOU
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
STAFF AND EVERYBODY WHO HELPED
PUT THIS ON. AND EVERYBODY HAVE
A SAFE REST OF YOUR DAY AND
WEEK THANK YOU THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.